hello ich bin phil spencer we at team
xbox are excited to be back at gamescom
to celebrate gaming with our fans from
all over the world whether attending the
show or watching from home
fans in germany europe and around the
world can expect a little more insight
into some of our previously announced
games coming to xbox in the next 12
months
we're excited to continue building a
community together and bringing the joy
of gaming to everyone on the planet
from all of us at xbox dankeshen and
welcome to gamescom 2022.
this has to be one of my favorite clips
and based on the video you just saw our
next two guests landed here at cologne
mesa in germany to talk all things
airborne i'm super thrilled to introduce
you the head of microsoft flight
simulator jack nyron and also the ceo of
asolo studio sebastian vlog thank you so
much for joining us thank you so much
maxie it's great to be back here at
gamescom
beautiful cologne and in person
thanks so much for having us thank you
and i heard you brought something
special with you today yes we did we
thought we have to rise to the occasion
and do something special and we we had
to come up with something new so for the
first time we're doing something called
city update which essentially means we
made five new photogrammetry cities here
in the area and we have a trailer so
let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
this looked incredible yeah i think i
even saw
five soccer stadiums at the episode if
i'll be cologne i wonder if we have any
cologne fans you're good
we look guilty i'm a big buddhist [ __ ]
fan and my my favorite club is astax
so so happy to put it into a video
but you had the spirit i hear it i hear
it still here but yeah really incredible
amazing thank you yeah photogrammetry is
awesome so just to explain we flew all
this last year
um so basically we have planes flying
really low taking a photograph a second
i'm sorry millions of photographs out of
that we built these 3d cities and so
it's it's beautiful and i hope i hope
the germans love it a little bit but
that's not the only thing that we did
for germany
so when we go into a region we try to do
a regional plane we call those local
legends it's a plane that is not that
well known in the world
but it's known in the country so last
year for gamescom we actually launched
the youngest u52 which is my personal
favorite plane and for this year we said
what are we going to do to top this and
we we are we are taking the sort of the
father of the younger 252 it's the
youngest f-13
which was the first metal transport
plane in the world so it actually
started airlines that one and um yeah so
we actually have a trailer so let's take
a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that trailer the music it really you
you're just bringing a beautiful piece
of history to life so thank you so much
for that and i'm wondering when you are
choosing a plane like the yonkos f13
like what is the process like to make it
as authentic as possible i'm assuming
you can't just like travel back in time
and talk to the german engineer hugo
juncker himself time travel step it's a
new feature we need we need to put that
in the flat time
no seriously so it's a ton of research
the first thing we do is are there any
surviving aircraft so this plane is from
1922
and we looked and there are pieces
so we first contact all the museums
where the pieces are and so in this case
the german museum deutsche mission in
munich has an original cockpit they had
it in storage we told them what our plan
were they're like we'll bring it out of
storage so we scanned that in down to
the millimeter and then um they also had
a replica so we've scanned the exterior
and then there's a company the yoga
company celebrated the 100 year
anniversary of this plane just recently
and they built three republicans so we
talked to that team as well and they let
us scan all the new instruments and they
had people who fly that so they gave us
feedback on the flight model and
everything to make sure that it's
perfect so it takes a ton of people but
it's great fun
so does that mean when you for example
decide on a new plane to bring back you
have a dedicated internal team that will
look after it or do you bring some
outside people in as well we bring
outside people in so this particular
plane is actually made by a german
engineer a software engineer his name is
oliver moser and he works with the
german museum and a whole bunch of other
people to really get it right
and the curators of those museums they
live those planes that's what they do in
their life right so they know everything
about everything we can ask them any
questions so that that's the process
with all with all the aircraft with new
aircraft sep is actually oftentimes
traveling yeah yeah uh just last summer
we visited a a school to fly on the
gimbal cabrio g2 when we when you do an
aircraft we make it extremely realistic
we go capture audio data flight data
visual data and we test the aircraft
with engineers from the manufacturers or
even test pilots and i mean that sounds
incredible but even more incredible is
flight sim is literally turning 40 this
year like it's i'm 38 i can't even
believe there is a game that is older
than me no but um it's really amazing
it's a milestone and you announced at
the xbox bethesda showcase that there
will be a 40th anniversary edition um
before we dive into that one
what does it feel like to run
microsoft's longest gaming franchise do
you have any key elements that you can
share yeah i mean it's it's like we're a
little bit in awe right we're living
history we feel very
um thankful we always say we're standing
on the shoulders of giants
bruce artwork made the first flight that
we invented the genre we tried to stay
very true to that fundamental vision and
i would say that what stands out to me
is the fans
we talk to them all the time there's
people that have been blitz flights in
for 40 years so they're in there in the
80s they know everything and they're
very vocal and active and that's what
makes it fun
when you're talking about the community
what have they been asking for for the
40th anniversary ah yeah so they started
they have a lot of requests but two that
stood out for us was helicopters and
gliders and sep his awesome team at the
sobo did a bunch of work so just talk
about that a little bit yeah so uh
helicopters and gliders they both are
very specific uh and uh they require a
lot more accurate simulation of the
airflow uh around the aircraft uh so for
example for helicopters uh they we have
the gimbal cabrio g2 uh we simulate a
thousand surfaces uh of the helicopter
instead of just one which was the
previous helicopter model um and we have
to simulate also the airflow around the
helicopter uh because the rotor
is what makes the helicopter fly and it
pushes the air downwards
so it creates very complex uh airflow
movements
to make it easier for uh people to
understand how this worked uh we have
added a visualization so people can turn
on and off
a tool that allows to see how the air
flows around the helicopter uh so when
you see the the air really uh how they
creates vortexes and how it creates
turbulences around the helicopter
and so there's very important effects
that uh account when you fly in
helicopter one of these is translational
lift
translationalist lift is when the
helicopter goes forward
it's easier for it to catch the air and
climb up and we actually flew the the
gimbal in july and it's very strong the
effect when you fly you go forward and
as soon as you go forward you get a lot
of lift and it really goes up
yeah another effect we have is the
ground effect uh when the propeller the
when the rotor pushes the air down it's
uh for the helicopter like climbing a
ladder that always goes down and when
you go closer to the ground the air is
blocked by the ground it goes down
slower and the helicopter can is more
efficient than climbing up
does that make just a question like
because you said july and it's very hot
that makes a difference right oh yeah
yeah uh the gimbal g2 has enough power
to easily climb vertically when it's
cold but in july when we flew it was it
was 100 degree fahrenheit and we
couldn't even go up vertically we had to
go up forward
yeah and another thing you said um it
sounds very dangerous that's like
this blade flapping i'm sorry oh yeah i
don't i don't have any aircraft
knowledge this deep but it sounds like
it's a it's a baby bird's first fly i
don't know almost it feels like wings so
uh the helicopter physics is really very
complex we had to push it up from 100
hertz to a thousand hertz so just to
capture a rotor going around
because it spins so fast and flapping is
when when the helicopter wants to go
left it needs to push on the left side
so the the rotor goes up and down and up
and down it actually resonates when it
turns around but everything is offset by
about 90 degrees because it's also soft
right it takes it takes time for the
rotor to bend and push the helicopter on
the other side
one important effect is the
groundwater the vortex effect with with
the ring vortex when when the helicopter
spins uh when the helicopter order spins
it creates a vortex when you go down it
goes into its own its own airflow its
own vortex and it's very hard for it to
climb at that moment
that i love these deeds i could i could
talk forever about this but i think the
most important question now is could you
explain a little bit um what is the
difference between a glider and all the
other aircrafts like yeah very important
a glider uh most of the guides don't
have a way to go up in the air so they
need to uh they need to find a way to
take off uh so they have a either a tow
plane or they will have a winch which is
gonna launch them into the air
and and once you're up there if you want
to stay in the air you need to find uh
places where the air goes up
and so uh uh experienced pilots will
know where to find updrafts but we added
a system for anyone to see them in the
environment so you can see the air
flowing up
and it's it's easier to find where that
happens uh and uh
the the the pilots can then fly in the
environment go up it's it's uh allows
you the glider has a very long
glide distance but when there's updraft
it can stay in the air for hours
basically as long as there is sunlight
and as long as it heats up the air
and then
it makes it yeah it makes it very fun
you can fly glide along uh mountains
on the hills where everything is south
exposed goes up and so it makes it a
very uh very complex and enjoyable
experience with its visualization you
spend clearly a lot of time in this um
have you shown this like to any pilots
or other people outside
yeah for example the helicopter
simulation we show that to uh
instructors of the same helicopter model
and they flew with it compared it to the
real-life helicopter they were super
impressed by how realistic this is how
it reproduces exactly uh the flight of
the helicopter and all the different
conditions and and for the for the
gliders we're actually working with the
studio called flight sim studio that
they are they're they're glider pilots
they know tons about that so yeah we
look for experts just to get back to
make it right
so since the instructors were so
impressed um would you think that the
community would be equally impressed
yeah we've been showing this a little
bit the visualization tools and all that
and you know in the past like our last
placement was called item 10. it was
basically a helicopter was a box with a
single point
now sap has thousands of points the the
physics simulation is out of this world
nobody's ever seen anything like this
before and they are over the moon
so they can't wait they can't wait so i
love hearing about helicopters and
gliders and planes do you have any other
aircrafts coming to the 40th anniversary
edition yeah so there's actually a big
the third big question from the
community was a it's called true to life
airliner that means you know airliners
are huge incomplex they have thousands
of buttons and true to life means that
every button does something so we work
with a team they're called any builds
they're experts they're doing an a310
airbus um and i think the community
can't wait i mean those things are
typically just pay aware and we now put
it into the base um i think it's like a
gift like the whole idea of the 40th
anniversary edition is like it's a box
of chocolate here's some gifts i like
chocolate i like chocolate what i like
more it's actually trailers do we have
one we do so just to speak to the rest
of the so we also want to celebrate
aviation you know aviation when you
think about it it's 120 years and we
have 40 of that so it's like let's let's
connect those things together so we
picked some of the classic planes from
the 1903 wright flyer and we spent like
five decades all the way to 1940s and we
do have a trailer for that and let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well it looks like we have a few more
surprises in this trailer and we have
some planes in there that we didn't see
before that is exactly true so there is
a kurdish jn4 jenny that's from 1915.
it's actually the plane they made
thousands of these and it's the plane
that everybody in like literally america
and also in europe trained so that's
when the airplane airplanes really took
off around that time and that plane is
at the center of all that then the next
plane we added was the the grumman goose
21 a beautiful plane it's sort of it's
famous because it shuffled hollywood
famous people to catalina island and
places like that with water planes so
it's lots of luminaries so there and a
lot of them are left because you know
honestly wealthy people had those planes
and then at the very end i don't know if
you saw that that huge plane that's the
huge edge for hercules it's better known
as the spruce ghouls so that's how it
uses um
you know he was a big ambitious guy so
he said i'm gonna build the biggest
plane ever made and forever and ever
this was the biggest plane in the world
and it only flew once for 20 seconds and
we worked very closely with the museum
there's a museum in oregon called
evergreen museum it's part of the
smithsonian organization
and we they have the plan so they let us
in there take photographs they give us
tons and tons of feedback and they're so
happy because this is going to be the
first time the spruce ghost really flies
that's going to be cool that is really
really amazing i'm not sure if that's
the one but i want to touch a little bit
on the legacy and maybe this is some of
the moments that captured this
four years of flight sim what has fans
coming back to the flight simulator like
every day
uh to me i mean we talk about this as a
team all the time to me it really is
like the the fundamental
truth is that the the flying is a human
dream and it's been a human dream for a
long time i honestly think people look
at the sky looked at the birds and said
man you know i wonder what that looks
like and the dream when bruce archway
started all this the dream was go
anywhere look at anything see it from
that very unique perspective of flying
and we stayed true to that the franchise
stayed true to that and i think that
dream is very much alive and still
shared and now with this new version
like it used to be we didn't have enough
data we couldn't really the planet
didn't really look like the planet when
we started this we had four petabytes of
data which is 4 000 terabytes a lot and
uh in the cloud so we now suddenly could
actually show every
house every building we have 1.5 billion
houses
we have four three three or four
trillion trees so we have literally
every house and every tree on the planet
and everything looks right so what
people are doing now is what i call
digital tourism so that's there was
always people interested in planes and
now people are also interested in the
world and let's just look at everything
and visit it and i think that's a new
dimension that we've added that that
brings in new people to this hobby and
it's a beautiful thing
so sebastian what's your experience in
this i mean aviation is so rich it's a
120 years of constant innovation there's
so many different things to discover so
many planes so many aircraft so many
helicopters
it's just very vast to explore and then
the playground is the planet right it's
it's huge you have so many cities
millions of cities you have so many
countries you can go travel prepare
travels uh there's just so fast there's
way more than 40 years of stuff to
discover
i have one question for you both because
i want to know
which is your favorite city to fly over
um that's a very good question so i
really like sydney
all right because i've never been and i
want to go because i saw how to fly so
i'm like and i actually landed
everywhere under the bay bridge or
whatever the the whatever the bridge is
called awesome i need to go in the real
world yeah what's yours the best it's
going to be san francisco san francisco
we've been there
we've been mine to see all like i've
never been there in korea like i want to
fly over that i spent a month in south
america i've never been to south america
i flew around for a month i now have a
sense what suriname looks like i had no
earthly idea right so but i it actually
sort of this itch to travel especially
during the pandemic i couldn't go
anywhere that really helped me and it
really brings the planet closer to you
it's great it does and there's nothing
like taking your halo pelican and hover
over your own street in munich i can
just recommend that
so the important question of course when
will fans be able to hop into the carpet
to take off with the 40th anniversary
edition yeah i mean so the 40th
anniversary edition is really is
releasing on november 11th so that's
three months from now it has it's a full
box of chocolates so we talked about
some planes it has 12 new planes it has
14 heliports 10 air glider airports it
has four classic airports we didn't
really ever talk about yet like flights
have always used to start in chicago on
max field that airport closed we didn't
have it in our original sim now we have
it there's others coming there's new
missions we're bringing missions back
from the old sim so i think it's a true
celebration of the franchise and um and
this in case people don't know the 40th
anniversary edition is in fact free for
people who are on xbox uh on game pass
and to or already own flight zone well i
love celebrations i love everything that
is free so i can't wait to hit the skies
with this 40 anniversary edition of
flight simulator thank you so much jack
thank you so much sebastian for coming
here and as you always say at the end of
your trailers the sky is calling
yeah see you in the skies
thank you so much thank you thank you
so before we hear from
before we hear from the folks behind
planet of lana let's visit a spooky
reimagine of boston in 1925. in this
uniquely mccaber mystery you inhabit the
bootstraps of a dashing detective
investigating a chilling murder with the
demon as your partner it's the classic
kind of good cop demon cop routine it
has full of puzzles an eye-catching art
style great action game play and a plot
that will have you at the end of your
seat check out the new trailer for this
wonderful unique looking adventure it is
the last case of benedict fox
[Music]
that's him
my father
what secrets did he take to his grave
glad you came back
my beautiful canvas
[Music]
your father's ego has suffered more than
the anticipated
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
benedict
coming up next is flake tail wiggram but
first charlie is standing by with our
very own erin greenberg and i have a
very special question for aaron can you
show us your nails
just like gaming is for everyone so is
getting your nails done and the xbox
controller colors thank you maxie that
was so great and now i've learned about
shellac it's a whole process right and i
feel like i'm in a secret beauty club
now or something he really is i do hope
you take these techniques back with you
to seattle maybe phil next a trends
maybe i'm in who's next let's do this
let's get the xbox sales trending
absolutely we're going to do it right to
the here and now how does it feel being
bagger games come after three years and
surrounded by this incredible community
this is like a dream come true yeah you
know for us at xbox like it always
starts with the fans it's about the fans
always yeah these are the most memorable
moments of all the years we love the
games they love the products but the
memories are great with fans are ones
that last forever and finally after
three years to be back here it's really
special it really is talking of memories
do you have any favorite ones and you
can't say talking to me three years ago
that was great planted so no i would say
listen we have done
fan fest that's always been kind of the
highlight of gamescom fans here in
germany fans from all over europe come
we've done parties on boats on the rhine
yeah we've done fanbase on a boat and so
this year you know we have a big booth
here at gamescom we did a a really great
after hours event just for fans last
night
and it was fun because we started giving
out prizes and then throwing controllers
into the crowd might have thrown a few
things sorry hey
it turned into like a sea shanty fast
and fans were singing sea shanties and
it was like
just the joy and love we get from our
fans it just warms our heart and uh we
miss this yeah absolutely and for those
who can be here this year what can they
expect from us on the booth at gamescom
well we have tons of playable so i mean
start maybe with pentiment so you know
obviously josh sawyer and the team
obsidian have been working on this
incredibly rich narrative adventure
taking us back to 16th century bavaria
so of course we had to launch it right
here in bavaria fans are loving it um
that's coming out in uh in november
we've got new age of empires four
updates yeah we do new tips coming those
are also free for h4 players we've got
some great partner titles here liza p
yep uh so if you were looking for like
that pinocchio meets bloodborne meets
game pass exactly a punishing childhood
game for everyone yes it is in the like
18 plus sections the secret bit over
there yeah
last case of benedict fox yes that was a
big highlight from showcase um and i got
to meet the team from plot twist they're
here from poland that's also nice
there's a lot of developers here that
are creating games for xbox and for pc
and for the ecosystem and to get to meet
those teams
it's also super special and then of
course for grounded the full release
september 27th we have a a giant 17 foot
over five meters wide yeah brood mothers
and i'm told that that's to scale as
well versus in game that's how big she
is yes so yeah we're having a great time
the boots filled with games filled with
fans and that's what gamescom is about
and it's just nice to finally be back
here and let people get to experience
some of that magic again nothing beats
in person 100 couldn't say about it
myself so thank you so much aaron uh
coming up next we'll get an inside look
at the much anticipated a plate tail
requiem
[Music]
far across the sea an island calls
the thing ever stays nice
it always sounds bad
things aren't always nice you can change
them
the way we always do
we fight
how far will you go to save the ones you
love
a plague tale requiem picks up a few
months after the end of innocence
right around the first days of summer
amesia and hugo are headed south along
with their mother beatrice and the young
alchemist lucas
reaching places still spared by the
devouring plague the raging wars and the
rabid rats that are running rampant in
the north
is that affair
beneath the warm sun of 14th century
provence
the darunes are almost able to enjoy a
normal life
[Music]
but for a recurrent dream that hugo has
been having of a mysterious island that
calls him
[Music]
how come nobody noticed that
disappearance maybe nobody cares
maybe one day the macular illness that's
been dormant inside hugo awakens
and the dreaded living nightmare begins
again
in the wake emacia finds herself with no
other choice but to trust her brother's
dreams and head further south towards
the elusive island
before he's consumed by the terrible
macular affliction the bite
yes they put the arena down they let
them die here
starting all over again
her mind is made up
she will find a cure in what dreams and
prophecy may hold get used to it with
almost no one they can trust this is
your life now emicia and hugo must
traverse land and water as restless
forces stand against them
after the events of last winter
emisia is hardened
experienced and when backed against the
wall can be surprisingly resourceful
with several new tricks up her sleeve
she is now able to freely choose between
striking from the shadows or unleashing
hell with a variety of equipment and
tools
hugo wants more than ever to help his
big sister and not hinder their progress
the macula within him is a double-edged
sword that has deepened his connection
with the rats
[Music]
this powerful ability can decimate
entire squads of soldiers
it takes a severe toll on hugo every
time
their journey brings not only hardship
but also unexpected friends these
colorful characters help the darunes
carry their terrible burden it's not my
first time while offering unique skills
and resources to bring them closer to
their elusive grains
[Music]
the road ahead will test the limits of
what they can endure on all levels
and just how far they're willing to go
reaching the island is only the first
step to truly understanding the terrible
affliction that stricken their family as
the lines between reality
fantasy and fate dissolve
keeping it together and finding the cure
to save hugo
will be nothing short of a miracle
but emesia has hope
and hope is the last thing lost
others
a plaguetale requiem releases october
18th on xbox series
[Music]
wow what a journey i don't know about
you but i've been eager to get back to
the rat infested france of the 14th
century which is a sentence i never
thought i'd say and it's in part thanks
to this guy over here kevin chateau game
director for a plague tell requiem
releasing this fall kevin thank you so
much for joining us today thanks for
having me i'm super happy to be here
it's such a good day so we're going to
dive right into that trailer as it
mentioned this is the follow up to the
smash hit innocence so i was wondering
if you can catch us up to where emisia
and hugo are up to now
so um the game takes place in the fourth
14th century south west france they are
they they came from the southwest
but they had to flee because of the
event of the first one
and so we joined them six months after
the event of the first one on the road
uh they are arriving in the province so
south east france and we are going to
explore this region and also a bit of
the mediterranean sea
lovely so for those who haven't or
people are waiting to jump right into
requiem i should say but maybe they've
not played innocence um would you say
it's recommended reading is it important
to go back i'm certain you'll say it is
but what do you think for new fans no of
course
yeah absolutely no no but it's um
[Music]
we have a re not rebooted but rethink
everything in the game so uh it's a
brand new game we have done everything
to uh on board everyone joining uh a
collected universe so even if you
haven't played the first one you can
jump in it it would be good for you
absolutely so i was actually wondering
if you could talk a little bit about the
um the sort of accessibility and the
onboarding that you've done and what you
had in mind during development what some
of the key changes coming to requiem
especially for those who loved the
original as well
so then
there's a lot of new things of course
you've seen it in a trailer um in terms
of gameplay it's much more wider bigger
much more open than the first one was
yeah i picked up on that actually yeah
yeah it was quite narrow the first one
so we were able to open it even further
and offer new tools to amissia like the
daily crossbow she has now
or the knife she can use quite the
arsenal she's got with her now yeah yeah
and then it's it's quite different for
us for her because now she's using war
weapon
it was not something she was doing in
the first one
so she she's ready to deal with death
much more than very ready deal with
death and deal out death by the looks of
the trailer so you mentioned the word
new a lot and i think it's important to
point out that this is the new console
generation that we're working with at
the moment so um what kind of shiny
current gen features can we expect to
see in requiem so there's many things
again um the first one that come in my
into my mind is uh we have uh pushed the
fascial expression the gmo cap even
further it was a brand new thing for us
we had no mockup on the first one so we
build up our studio we've learned new uh
new ways to work so we've improved this
aspect of the game and visually it's
much more stunning than the first one
was
with
we wanted a larger game as i was saying
but we needed then more light because
the light is the key element of our
gameplay i love the way every new thing
brings its own problems that you have to
overcome yeah so we are
much more wider out so it means more
light light is very
expensive in terms of
performances for the game so it was a
big challenge but also of course wider
space we need
to fill it with something yeah
so we jump up from 5 000 to 300 000 rats
on the screen that's a lot of rats to
begin with so sorry say that one more
time that's 5 000 to 300 000 yeah that's
it
are you not okay that's a lot of rats to
put in the video
game well i was gonna say well thanks to
all of those rats it does mean that um
when we say that amisha and hugo have
been through quite a lot i think it's a
little bit of an understatement
especially now um and at the end of the
day they're actually still children if
they're anyone out there who didn't know
that much background from the story so
um how do you go about showing their
relationship in an authentic way after
everything that they've been through
together it's about to do that because
they've been through a lot they have
experience
they were almost
dead sometime and a lot of people around
them
died
so they have to grow up be much more
mature than
what they should be at their age
it's super hard to build up a
story and convey a
convincing dialogue
for children
fortunately the team is quite old now
and
ages part number
but
and we a lot of us have children so we
we can
be inspired by them and and try to feel
the best way to convey uh children
emotion to the players it must be a very
difficult one to do though i mean as a
parent myself like i can only reasonably
say that i hope i never see my children
go through what happens in that game so
what's that sort of like to go yeah
we're reflecting the childlike
experience in the game but
also committing terrors to them yeah
this this is something we have no
no inspiration from to take from because
yeah again you don't want to be inspired
by that too
of course no
yeah well fair enough um we're going to
focus a little bit now specifically on
amisha uh as in innocence we saw her
wielding a crossbow um she's way more
prepared she's way more confident
dangerous and all round i think you'll
agree a bigger all-round hero to hugo so
how do tactics change in requiem and
what does that mean for the people
playing as her so um yeah as the
prepared is the is the right word uh
she's
she's ready she don't want uh just only
to survive or to escape she's ready to
fight if she needs to absolutely but
she's not forced to
so the player can choose the way you
will approach this oh interesting okay
so you can go
full stairs if you want you can go full
combat everything is still there from
the first one so that's right now you
can choose uh to approach a situation
the way you want
so it's not that only the space that is
wider but also the way you will approach
things yeah and by full combat you me i
mean we saw some stuff from the trailer
like you all of combat right yeah yeah
you can burn people you can use the
crossbow to kill them instantaneously or
you can use the knife to silently kill
them it's all there it's absolutely all
there and i think that all comes
together and making the experience so
much more cinematic
um which i want to talk about now
because the other thing that's so
fantastic about the title is the voice
acting and i think that becomes
essential when you want to convey
emotion so i'd love for you to share a
little bit of insight about the
development process working with the the
voice actors and getting to the voices
of the emotion that we hear in that
trailer
so it's funny because it's something
that uh people don't really know but
when we are working on the game for
several years
we don't work with voice actor and
stanton usually so for like two or three
years we work with a text-to-speech so
robot voices
and for an emotional game it's a bit
hard it takes you out a little bit yeah
it's like when you use your smartphone
it's a flat voice
with no emotion no punctuation nothing
that makes really sense so it's really
hard to keep your focus on the story
some time to understand what is the
purpose of seconds
it's yeah after 16 hour of breakthrough
you're like
uh i think i don't get the story at all
sure interesting that it changes that
much i will say first of all i would
love to see that version one day it does
sound wonderful um so do you wanna what
was the process like working with the
voice actors so when the voice actor
arrives it changed everything
because we were
able to work again with charlotte
mcburley and
logan
which were the actor for amisha hugo
from the first one
and
we were so in love with their height
acting it was a game changer for us to
have them back in the game
um
they
when they arrived their voices arrive in
the game uh the game
uh i was going to say imagine it's a
little bit of a chicken and egg
situation with voice acting who informs
the character is it you guys designing
the character or does the voice act to
come in and actually completely change
the scene actually it's both yeah we
prepared everything and they react to
what we've wrote and they say no i think
i'm should say it like that a bit more
like that so we change that on on the
fly with them and adapt the game
sometimes to their their feedback to
make it even better and even more
accurate they are still children and we
are not anymore so i love that they have
their own feedback as well it's their
character right it's it's their
character that they're conveying so big
love for them to feed him back as well
right well lastly for anyone who is
watching this segment out there who
can't wait to play requiem in october
which by the way is day one on xbox game
pass um and maybe you're not here in
gamescom as well i'd love to know what
you would like to tell the folks at home
about requiem so we're super glad to
have it day one on that on the
um on gamepass because it means that a
lot of players will be able to try the
game and to give us feedback because i
really want to see their reaction you
know i can't wait to see that we've
built up the games in several years and
we write up this big story and i really
want to see people reaction to that and
the community have been really close
since the first title as well yeah yeah
and it's thanks to them that we were
able to do the sequels so uh um yeah
we're super loved letter to them yes by
the courier device of rats 300 000 of
them to be nice 300
000 rats of love
absolutely fantastic well thank you so
much for joining me i'm a massive fan of
series and i cannot wait to get my hands
on it thank you again yeah thanks so
much for joining us but when it comes to
self-care you can't be a re-watch of the
disney classics right i know i certainly
can't yet in recent years many of us
have also sought comfort in virtual
worlds millions of players have found
solace in games that allow us to
customize islands build unique homes and
share virtual spaces with friends when
we can't actually see them in person our
next trailer builds on that idea and
takes it to a whole new world so to
speak here's an all new look at disney
dreamlike valley
hello everyone i went on a wonderful
adventure today in dreamlight valley and
i want to share it with you
it started with my favorite song on the
radio don't you just love when that
happens it put me in the best mood ever
so i picked out my look for the day i
was in the mood for something
adventurous and i had the perfect outfit
i was feeling a bit creative so i added
a little touch of magic to my look and
then i was off
i made my way to shae remy for brunch i
love cooking with remy i was feeling
some mickey waffles with jam but it
turns out we were fresh out of fruit
raspberry jam is my favorite so i headed
up to the forest of valor to pick some
and while i was there i heard a sound
from the frosted heights bio
but i just couldn't cross the bridge
i'll have to adventure back there to
check it out my stomach started to
rumble so i headed back over to the
plaza and we were ready to cook i always
learned something new with remy there
are so many recipes to try to create the
perfect disney themed meal
ah here we go i even whipped up an extra
and shared it with kristoff after brunch
the weather was just so perfect that i
couldn't resist going for a walk and
some shopping while looking in the
windows of scrooge mcduck's general
store i ran into scrooge himself he
asked for my help spreading the word
around town about his shop of course i
said yes
so i headed over to my crafting table
whipped up a few signs and place them
around town i was exhausted after so
much excitement and i just felt like
relaxing a bit so i decided to move my
house over to dazzle beach to watch the
sunset when i set up my house i noticed
a strange pillar merlin had quite a
story to tell about it i put up the
perfect hangout spot and i invited ariel
to hang out because happy moments are
always better when you share them with
friends it really was a perfect day in
dreamlight valley
pre-order disney dreamlight valley now
ahoy there welcome my name's adam park
and i'm head of brandon license in a
rare and i am joined today by three
members of the cr3 coup see your three
crew i mean
yeah it's kind of work
i'll go along the road so we've got joe
needs executive producers on sea of
thieves we've got mike chapman who's our
creative director and then we've got joe
who is our senior community manager so
how is everyone
excited tired everything all of the
above like a wonderful mix you get at
events yeah yeah feeling the buzz of the
live show yeah
the energy so awesome i mean it is our
first official
show since 2019
so how is it actually being i mean i'm
sure everyone's asking the same question
but how is it back at a show with people
overwhelming but in the best way right
like it really is like it's just
the the passion the excitement of buzz i
think that we all have coming to a show
like this right and and and kind of
meeting the fans but then giving back to
us from everybody that we see it's just
like it's it's incredible like which
we've brought so much money of the team
here we've got about 30 i think with us
like um and
because it's just so valuable bringing
people to shows getting that buzz
getting that energy that you just take
back to the studio to kind of just pour
into more sea of thieves though yeah
absolutely 2019 but it feels so much
longer yeah but the first live show seen
for us since 2019 so exactly what joe
said feeling the buzz from the fans and
we get to take that energy back to the
studio to keep making this and so joe
this is your first
official sea of thieves event yes first
official sea of thieves event and first
gamescom general
it's amazing like obviously we had a
little taste of this
end of july with software
and that was wonderful to see the fans
in person after so long and for the
first time for i think a lot of us um
and now we've brought it to gamescom and
some of them are here and you're seeing
them again and recognizing them and you
get that real sense of what it means to
them to be a part of this community and
we've got all sorts going on on the
staff so i'll show off so we've got the
we've got tattoos
we've got gold hunters live which people
can tune into you can come and win
things photo arts meet the team so it's
great being back but so obviously it's
been three years since we've done
anything like this what's going on
generally mike i'm going to ask you to
start with sure sea of thieves has
anything happened in the last three
years
what haven't we done
i think like
a passion has always been to keep
building ends higher over the last three
years you think back at the things that
we've added we've added the emissary
system but the players can go and role
players their trading companies for
extra rewards we've added new quest
types we brought in our seasonal
progression systems we brought in our
adventures we brought in our mysteries
we brought in like all these new ways to
play and one of the key ones of course
was their collaboration with disney on
pirates life and you know since 2019.
thank you sir
just keep going yeah yeah and one of the
big ones was um
what happened with the pirates life so
working with disney we built all of that
during the pandemic you know being at
home
working with this team we've worked
together for so long all of these
incredible bonds and relationships that
we built allowed us to get through what
was a very hard time the country is
stronger as a team and we're more
passionate than ever and obviously joe
you joined steve thieves during the
pandemic how has it been like that
dynamic of actually coming into the
studio it's the best thing like you get
a real sense since day one of how
closely the team works together and how
approachable everyone is there's no one
that you can't just drop a message to
but that translates over to the studio
where we've got such a wonderful
creative nurturing environment but you
can go and knock on the door of anyone
or bump into them into the corridor and
conversations spark from that it's it's
such a wonderful thing to now have that
everyone's not just behind a screen
anymore and how do you feel joe i mean
again it's been a long three years we've
achieved a lot in that time as if you're
being back somewhere like this with what
we've done well well honestly like
i think we were talking about this kind
of earlier right like like you were
talking about during the pandemic the
team's all separated but being back in
the studio you just get that energy that
you feed off each other you feed off
kind of the team and the people around
you and coming to a show like this you
kind of get that same thing like i said
just you feed off the energy like and
even though we're exhausted and we've
always saw a person i've got a cough
suit in my mouth at all times like water
on hand like but it is what i promise um
but uh it's just
it just gives you this energy and desire
and passion to just like want to go back
to the studio and just pour it into your
work and pour it into the game and you
kind of want to take it and bottle it
right and then take it back to the whole
studio like we always do when we go back
we do we take photos and videos and do a
big presentation and really try and just
get people to understand what it's like
to meet the fans right and
you get the afterglow and this is what
we'll experience next week we'll have
this wonderful gamescom afterglow as we
get to take that back to the studio like
joe said and
put it into all the ambitious things
we've got planned for this year and
beyond well before we get on to that
jesus and the light
you did like you mentioned it one of the
things we introduced in the last few
years was seasons
season seven yeah just gone live a
couple of weeks back indeed and it's a
biggie it is a big it's a biggie so
like what have you and i'm going to
start with you mike i will come to you
what have you kind of enjoyed seeing
people do and what has season seven like
introduced to cfp
well season seven you're right is a big
one and
the idea of being a pirate captain in
our world the idea that your ship
becomes
uh
it becomes an embodiment of who you are
in this world and your pirate journey
captaincy extends that pirate journey it
allows you to as a community have often
requested to name your ship for the
first time to have this persistent
identity for your ship but beyond that
we're bringing in new progression
elements we're bringing in the captain's
log bringing ways that your session and
the ship now feels like a home so based
on how you play your ship represents who
you uniquely are as a pirate and how you
play in sea of thieves so i think one of
the most important things that has meant
a lot to us seeing the reception he's
just seeing players go all in on that
role play you know we're going all in
the idea of this is who i am and when
you board someone's ship that
representing who they are in the sea of
thieves and why captaincy now what made
sense to bring it in at this point well
it's one of those features i think we
were always going for doing yeah um what
made sense now was and it kind of goes
back to the question around what's
happened in the last three years we
think about how much richer that cfd's
experience has become there's so many
ways to play in sea of thieves you know
there's so many ways to be who you
uniquely are as a pirate where the
sandboxes got richer there's new
activities there's new quest there's new
enemy threats there's just new ways to
play so captaincy coming in now and
rewarding you for all the unique things
that's now in the sandbox it kind of
just puts this lovely new layer to that
pirate journey and it just celebrates
this rich game that sea of thieves has
become and i suppose joe from a
community perspective you must have seen
this played out in real time like how
has the community taken to captaincy
that's the thing like
from day one they've been asking when
can we name our [ __ ] when can we do this
and then we've not only delivered that
we've delivered so much more on top of
it that people now have this pirate
identity that until now was just
conversations or role plays and we've
got people that are going for all those
fishing trinkets or people like myself
that it's it's all can inspired and
fought of the dams that you've completed
and you've got that real sense of
identity now from our players because
they can represent themselves on their
ship and they're
color coordinating everything and
they're decorating and they're
playing how they've always played but
now they're rewarded for it with their
own identity
and they absolutely adore it it's
wonderful
we wanted the idea that pirate captains
in a world like heirs would become the
vips yeah they become the rock stars of
the world so as part of captaincy and
that big update that we brought in
there's a set of perks and conveniences
that captains now have so when you own
your first ship in the sea of thieves
there's a unique cashing point just for
you in the cnt's world to make
offloading that treasure it was part of
going out there and having adventures
making that feel so much more efficient
using the harpoon to harpoon the
treasure off the deck cashing that
treasure really efficiently but
alongside that as well you've got the
new trinket system so
this new progression system that they
should unlock these trophies that
represent who you are there's the
captain's voyages so you can select
exactly what you want to do and store
all of the voyages that you could do on
this bookcase immersively in the
captain's cabin
as part of that as well you can go to
the shipwrights and you can purchase
resources right there from the outpost
and have them delivered to your barrels
so the idea that if you are a ship
captain in the sea of thieves you can
get your ship ready quickly you can pick
the adventure you're going to go on and
you can just walk straight on that ship
and have your adventures and then that
adventure be persistent there's that
sense of consequence for your actions
your ship showing the battle scars of
all your adventures you choosing to
maybe you want to keep that maybe you
want to role play with this kind of
battle scarred ship or you can pay a
small amount of gold to make the whole
pristine again so it really strengthens
and really amplifies everything that's
already unique about that second option
is me i have to pay to get it redone i i
get in too many fights
i love that though i love the way it
just allows players to be more uniquely
who they are yeah and like being out on
the waves and looking through the spy
glass and seeing all these ship names
and hero players chosen to represent
themselves i mean that that's the magic
and today it's enriched the sandbox to
see these and that's what we always want
to do so
i'm going to go now so we mentioned ship
names it's a biggie big part of
captaincy
you don't have to tell me but i'm going
to ask a couple of you this what did you
name your ships i'm going to start with
you joe
so my name's my sloop is little foot
my rare loadout rig is get red nice nice
galleon which is the one that we use the
most so if you see it on the seas come
and say hello and that's the purple
loadout and that is the purple rain with
the quartermaster sales there we go nice
nice how about you mike okay so i've got
a sloop and a break so for the sloop the
sloop is called the golden blade so fan
to see if these will know that
the silver blade the burning blade it's
a big part of their law so the golden
blades a little tease prayer fans maybe
someone that's really into the law but
my sleep is called the golden blade and
my brig is called inferno
and that is actually a reference to
one-eyed willy's ship inferno in the 80s
classic the goonies and why mike is the
goonies so because it's something that
comes up like white back i know and joe
it's because the 80s was the best decade
like they all don't like that's nice
there are no contests broadcast over
yeah
we like you took the whole team to see
the goonies during development we did we
hired a cinema
we had the electric cinema out in
birmingham very lovely independent
cinema um but yeah it had some
pirate themed cocktails that they put on
and yeah we took the whole time to see
it because it was all about that
camaraderie that adventuring together
right in all seriousness like it's hard
not to get emotional when joe that's
such an incredible memory of the
development to see thieves and
in such a deep and meaningful way when
we went to watch the goonies together it
felt like we as a team were about to
embark on our own pirate adventure like
the characters in that movie and we knew
we wanted to create a game where the
bonds between the crew felt like the
bonds between the characters in the
goonies they're on this pirate adventure
they don't know what's going to happen
they're going to be surprised by all the
dangers and the peris that come their
way so
the goonies for us is just it's a lovely
memory but it's it really feels in tune
with the spirit of what sea of thieves
has always been yeah so joe instead of
asking you what your ship's called well
no one's asked me no one's asking you
mine was notorious brg which
works verbally doesn't work when written
anyway
so what's some of the favorite ships
you've seen though so what i love about
like the ship naming throughout the
community is obviously people trying to
make humorous things try and make stuff
that it's gonna get a reaction or get a
chuckle from from people when they look
through the kind of spy glass and see it
and stuff so like socks so sot final
boss like that that gave me a little
chuckle right that did like it's like
you see that it's like yeah i love that
people like role-playing as the fearsome
kind of
ai threat in the world but i just love
it i love that anything that makes me
chuckle is what gets me right there's so
much of that but that was that was one
that stuck in my head that i think
someone tweeted from the god of reddit
or something but yeah and what about you
mike any favorites that is a great
example
hey we're awesome players have got this
new way to express their creativity and
to see if the world and the fact that we
can laugh about it together but honestly
there's so many examples but um you
saying boat yeah referencing you saying
bolt the olympic medalist that made me
chuckle um i like the way that you felt
like you had to explain that
world known olympic medalist uh but one
one that i just can't forget it's a
little bit dark
but um
she kept the house
beautiful that's it really difficult
that is good
how about you joe honestly the
the really obvious ones are the ones
that make me giggle i ran across the
galleon that was just this boat is big
yeah and that was like yeah yes
on your way it is
and it's those ones that i like but you
see them once you say you've got the
role-playing ones where they've gone for
some variation on something we've gone
and got in-game or you've got just the
funny puns that we've seen as well and
it's that creativity that you see and
you're like
you can almost judge what kind of pirate
they are yeah but not all the time and i
love that yeah you're right actually
because if someone's got a humorous like
this boat is big thing you can imagine
approaching them maybe like having a
life with them right and speak to them
over you know using the speaker jumping
or something yeah yeah so yeah you're
right actually it really adds a kind of
different sort of feeling doesn't it to
encounter other ships so i do actually
have the top ten boat names oh oh okay
this is where we would have top of the
pops music okay for people of a certain
vintage
does anyone want to guess see if anyone
guess what number one is i just flashed
it at the camera
i would say knowing them knowing their
fans knowing gay community and the role
play of the world and generally how
things go down i would
i would predict
something like the black person you
would be quite right mike yeah and
collect your gift there's a lot of black
there's a lot of black pearls out there
and
how awesome is that and that's that
original creativity and humor that we
love today for players yeah
come on let's
let people role play let people roll
plays what the game's all about and you
go joe
it's like pearl's in there yeah there's
gotta be a flying dutchman you would be
quite right up three
no actually he's number seven
so are you uh usain bolt correct there
you go that's it so others in the top
ten i'm not going to do an exhaustive
list but we have sloop dog
dog that's very good we have
why
why the letter y i don't want an
existential crisis while i'm sailing
why why is this just like everybody's
just like why don't come out here
look at that you looked really troubled
by that i am troubled i don't i don't
understand that one unless it's so if
your ship's named why get in touch
actually yes let us know
[Laughter]
oh yeah right okay
mary and queen anne's revenge
right so moving on then well any of
those cfts there's no
we're just getting into that section
yeah yeah yeah everyone just like no
adventure six then
so it's live right now people are
playing as we speak so
can you mike probably best give us an
overview of where this fits within the
law and the story where are we yeah so
we're in a really interesting time in
the sea of thieves now in our
storytelling where
it's set against the backdrop of these
emerging factions in the sea of thieves
and
our players will know that last as part
of the pirate's life the dark brethren
emerged working with davey jones and of
course davey jones got defeated because
of the valiant efforts of their players
but the dark brethren are still around
with amarantha their new member who's an
ex-sea dog and we've got everybody's
favorite duke so there's the dark
brethren there's of course the one and
only pirate lord and he's pirate legends
part players are often part of that and
we've got
the third
area of that third faction which is of
course uh captain flame heart of captain
flame heart and the reaper's bones and
the servant of the flame so what you're
seeing now at this point in seattle's
history is this factional war between
these pirate groups that have all got
their own vision for the pirates life
and the way they want the pirates life
to be in the sea of thieves and
unfortunately
paul merrick has got himself ensnared in
the middle of that and in adventure six
players are recruited by the pirate lord
to go on this daring rescue mission into
the sea of the damned to the new hideout
of the dark brethren which is the
twisted sea dog tab and a memory of that
iconic sea dogs tavern from the main
world and you work together with crews
to save merrick but
one of the big things that players with
played will always already realize is
this actually brings a chapter of
merrick's story that began with a hunger
indeed continued with the shrouded d to
the forsaken hunter where merrick was
unfortunately killed and went to the sea
of the damned to knowing hunter's cry it
brings this chapter of merrick's story
to a touching conclusion the story is
not over but it brings this part of the
story to a conclusion so definitely
worth experiencing that story because
it's going to have important
ramifications
so i met someone yesterday here and
they're a massive fan of merrick and
they wanted to talk to you about that
they had some questions deals can always
be struck yeah and i'm open to ideas but
it's merry course shelling yeah
[Laughter]
so how far
are the adventures planned and like and
without teasing anything or giving
anything like how far out are we looking
in terms of where do you know the story
is how far out really far so i think
what's really cool
like thematically like where we want to
go and the direction we're heading into
and how we want to represent the pirates
life in all these different ways in the
sea of thieves that is planned out
multiple years worth
at a high level in terms of absolute
specifics of what the story beats are
and exactly which character is involved
and in what way that's planned out it
means it's probably a year a year and a
half's worth of storytelling and
adventures that we've got planned out
and we need to do that because that's
the way that you make things meaningful
and make it feel authentic to the sea of
thieves when we know that we know what's
going to happen with character in a year
and a year and a half's time we can
start seeding things early start
bringing players organically into that
storytelling we love to do that because
it makes everything feel more meaningful
and how do you think the community like
engage with the law like is it because
obviously it's not a pre-requisite to
playing the game but those who love law
love law oh yes they do that i was going
to say you have to get those specifics
right because if one
thread is out of place if one character
isn't in the right look they're going to
notice and they're going to tag mike on
twitter until he answers for his lore
crimes
they know their stuff that's the thing
because they've been so invested since
day one and we've now stepped it up with
the amount of law we're delivering
and i know across our social channels
and on discord we've got separate
channels and we had to separate out the
launcher section because we've got
mysteries and adventures and then
general law and they're all over it and
they're sharing theories and they're
swapping stories and they've thoroughly
embraced that side of the storytelling
that we've got now
and i love that i love it i mean that's
to me shows that a lot of their
community are invested in the world and
they care about our world and you're
right of course it's not a pre-requisite
place here sea of thieves is this
wonderful sandbox adventure game where
you get to choose your own adventures
but we've always believed that the more
meaning and purpose we can put into the
world the deeper we can make that world
feel
the easier it is to immerse yourself in
those adventures and that role play so
it's there waiting full of surprises for
players that want it but it's not a
prerequisite for seafood and how do we
bring you like expanded universe into
this
like you know again with the planning
we need to know what's coming but like
you know say the the most recent novel
we planned that was it two years ago we
had the first pregnancy quite a long
time ago wasn't it yeah so how it's like
how do you kind of keep all of this is
there a
is there a big board with lots of
we do have we do have a law bible
um which is which is quite high level if
it was too detailed it would get
hundreds and hundred thousands of pages
probably um but it's a lot of meetings
it's a lot of discussion it's a lot of
building up that knowledge together as a
team i mean you're right everything in
the eu is canon to our story so what
players have seen before with the tells
the cfp's law book the two novels that
we've never got out the rpgs and the
expansion all of those stories are canon
to our world and there's a huge
responsibility that comes with that
experiencing any of those materials
should be just another window into the
cft's world and when you play the game
it should strengthen and vice versa both
of those elements so we have to get it
right every time that's well that's the
pressure yeah
so
we had our first decision point
adventure
where the community effectively decided
wrongly
can we edit this out isn't it
today so the community were able to
decide the fates of the world so we're
going to start asking what side will you
wore on so i i was ruined golden sands
yeah
how about yourself don't remind me joe
i'd actually forgotten that you were on
that side
save golden sands you're surrounded all
the way i am so i mean i'm ending
no i think
as i mean as we've seen today
interacting with people here at gamescom
merrick is such a beloved character and
what merrick stands for and you know
he's a salty pirate that's lived his
life in the cities and people love that
character and i think for me
it's such it's a more interesting story
and i'm it's unbelievable that the
community chose to go that way the fact
that they bonded together to take this
positive action to defend goldman sachs
so which side are you joe i think we can
guess we're in golden sands like
absolutely and then obviously all on the
side of sea of thieves sorry i was going
to make it i'm going to move away from
that i was going to make a soon act
trust no that would do that but we won't
do that because
moving on quickly did we have the result
you expected genuinely no it was well
i don't i don't i can predict no
i kept i kept watching the conversations
happening and we we'd made all these fun
things across our discord servers so
that people showed their allegiance
rather than anything else
and the reaper's hideout was just
burning stuff lyrics was coordinating
and i had no way of knowing which way it
was gonna go
and as much as i wanted to ruin it i'm
not gonna lie i spawned in my first
place session afterwards on golden sands
and was really happy i was like look at
it i think as a designer you think you
think so much about
the psychology of players and how
they'll react to certain things and
i genuinely believe personally that it
would go the way it would go to that
negative choice it would go to the
reaper they choose chaos who wouldn't
want to see what happened if the reapers
won because golden stands it's about
taking it back to that neutral state
which which it will evolve now because
the choice has been made but i always
thought people would side with the
reapers so
just blown away by the fact that didn't
happen i thought that was a lovely
surprise and it's going to be really
interesting as players see throughout
this year
what's going to happen to golden sands
now and how that's going to play out
yeah
and honestly and i love the
knowing kind of what the next decision
point is and where the kind of where
we're leading to like that is going to
be another huge moment for our community
to have to again make a choice right and
the impact that's coming with that like
without teasing too much but it's like
you know later this year there's going
to be another big one like i think
bigger in terms of kind of emotional i
think yeah the emotional investment in
the next one i think will be bigger well
so i'm going to ask again you've kind of
preempted the question but all right
so with we're having another decision
point that's happening yeah okay there
we go
is this bigger similar what can people
expect
bigger
it's absolutely bigger it cuts right to
the core of
some of the key characters in the sea of
thieves and we wanted to do that we we
wanted to drive a big world change with
gold and sands obviously we set that up
for the first adventure trader island
um and picking golden sands because it
was a beloved outpost beautiful palm
trees it's paradise we knew that would
trigger an emotional response for our
players but
we've done that now we've seen how
players interact with it we've learned
some lessons about how to set up these
type of live storytelling events and now
we're going to go even further we're
going to be even more ambitious with
these second choices yeah so look out
for that and also mechanically again
without spoiling it but you've learned a
lot from how we designed the first one
and the activities people were doing and
how we're going to be kind of like i
love what we've got planned there in
terms of like the yeah just the
activities people are going to be doing
and how that's going to play out and how
it's just going to make the the whole
sea of thieves feel so different during
that time period yeah yeah it'll be
it'll be a real moment in time and joe's
right we've deliberately in adventure so
far done very different things
one's more focused on the pure gameplay
one's more focused on the storytelling
all these different set pieces because
we're we're learning and we're going to
take those learnings into the future
adventures that we've planned out we're
already doing that and you've touched on
it slightly there but how how is it
planned like in terms of production as
executive producer
[Laughter]
production
director
like how do you kind of prepare for that
decision point though like you know do
we have both tracks ready to go or is it
more of a case of well we assume this
will happen or we have a more neutral
state
[Music]
that genuinely is probably one of the
most complex things we've ever done well
you've got like two videos
um but you've got to plan for both
outcomes we deliberately don't start
building the bigger things yeah because
that would be an incredible waste of the
team's time with the more valuable
things but we have to plan out a
junction point so earlier on when i was
talking about the fact that we've got
adventures planned out for the next year
and a half there's almost a fork in the
roads there where there's almost option
and there's option b based on some of
these community choices that we're
planning so it makes a complex job even
more complex but
like so worthwhile yeah so worthwhile to
see that play over the community um and
joe just kind of we're going to wrap up
in a moment but like from what you know
of the next decision point like do you
think we're going to see that kind of
ground swell from the community i guess
like they're gonna i think they're gonna
go wild for the next one i think it's
really exciting and with that other
decision point they've seen how they can
alter the world that they're playing in
and that most of them spend a lot of
their time in and i think this next one
really is going to step it up and i
think we will see that
resurgence of the passion that we saw in
the last decision point and then some
so to wrap up then we're here for a
couple more days what can people expect
like from us at gamescom just come to
the stand basically like there's always
going to be a thieves crew at the stand
right and each day we have a look
there's a meet and greet slot that we've
tweeted out i don't know when but it's
five o'clock today
and then one o'clock i think every other
day i think but um
uh and then yeah you could come play you
can win the medallions like you can
watch the stream but but the whole point
we're here is just to chat and meet with
fans right that's why we've brought so
many people here that's the energy we
want comment and come and give my
feedback and questions specifically on
merrick yeah yeah specifically
i love it honestly that is that is the
privilege of being at a live show like
this nothing energizes you more than
talking to fans feeling their passion
hearing their questions and their
feedback we don't just want to hear the
good stuff we want to hear the bad stuff
yeah we want to learn we want to make
this service of sea of thieves in this
pirate world the best it can possibly be
if you love pirates sea of thieves
should be the game for you so we love
nothing more than talking to our fans we
love the game as much as their fans do
what a wonderful place to leave
any questions about scotland bones
but this has been great so thank you
ever so much and as joe says if you are
here do you come down and see us please
do please don't honestly but if not um
we'll see you on the seas
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
has fallen humanity is hanging on by a
threat but you know what it's not all
bad news because our planet is full of
badass dinosaurs and seriously who
doesn't love a dinosaur seriously
in this exciting new glimpse at second
extinctions full release players get to
explore more of earth than ever before
the full launch adds a new vast open map
for players to roam more dinosaurs to
fight a revamp progression system and
tons of exciting new features i mean i'm
talking about co-op first person shooter
and mutated dinosaurs i am so in
here's a brand new trailer for second
extinction
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you hear me
i hope this reaches you
this city is falling apart
chaos
madness
death
and there might be no going back
[Music]
but you can change that
it depends on the choice you make
truth
or lies
but i don't have a choice
only you can do this
please
help me
finally
we meet
son
[Music]
the stage is set
the light shines brightest in the
darkest of times
all right i'm here for you don't worry
you can leave
protect
full
your destiny
hello charlie here with two of the
brilliant and twisted minds from neowiz
who created a game that's reimagined
pinocchio as a
a ruthless killing machine to cleanse a
plague infested world made by the studio
behind beloved fantasy mmo bless
unleashed and coming from a team of
developers who worked on the absolutely
awesome monster hunter world i am super
excited about this one please welcome
juwon choi and jason park
it's lovely to meet you whoever's
underneath there um
this is haunting
truly haunting
should we have a look and see if we can
find the humans underneath yeah let's go
let's do it yeah i'm gonna do the slow
reveal
here they are
jason and juwon
[Laughter]
we have a joker
hello nice to meet you there they are
amazing they've joined us welcome now
when i think of pinocchio it doesn't
quite look uh up to the trailer that we
saw just now so could you let us know
where the idea of pinocchio is killing
machine actually came from
our team is called off and this is the
first time we've developed a single
player console game so we need a way to
get our name out there
in order to stick in the minds of the
people our strategies was to choose our
songs that was very well known but
transform it into something completely
original
um we eventually choose the adventures
of the pinocchio but there wasn't no key
decisions
we first thought about what features we
wanted our social life game to have and
the first don't ever reference the taco
fantasy or unbelievable thing the second
the story shouldn't be chinese and we
should be able to enjoy it as it or
dutch and last
the game should be full of adventures
and unforgettable characters
this is natural related to pinocchio
because it matched the conditions we
excelled
i had a lot of pinocchio when i was
child but i was shocked when i leave
again more carefully recently the
adventures of the piano kill is
definitely not a story for children but
rather like an r-rated movie for adults
it was a real pleasure to take the
fantastic source material and create our
own original story tell really i bet it
is and now we're at gamescom showing it
off to the world
so very prompted the initial idea of
making a game based on the story of
pinocchio
honestly i was not convinced at all
yeah
i was thinking that
pinocchio is a story for just for kids
that children pro or nike thought like
games
however even though i read the pinocchio
story long time ago
i i live in my family so i went to
bookstore bought a book and read it
again
and what i've learned is that
pinocchio is not just a character it's
more like a reflection of human nature
and filled with a lot of your unique and
attractive characters
that's when i realized
we need some
this is something we have to do
revitalizing this amazing story as a
game i think it sounds like i might need
a reread of pinocchio then um but until
then do you want to give us a bit of a
deep dive of the story in the world that
your pinocchio inhabits
as you already know elijah p is based on
the original story of pinocchio
which is actually quite a brutal
and while the main characters in elijah
p are for the pinocchio our game's story
is completely different and filled with
new events for example larger pe takes
place in the imaginary city of aquat on
where petrification disease is spreading
and causing a lot of conflict
and while you meet a lot of familiar
characters from the pinnacle
they want to be anything anything like
you remember yeah we introduced the
black lobby brotherhood before
uh but i'd also like to tell you about
antonia who appears at the beginning of
the trailer
and the original story antonia is
actually antonio yeah japito's friend
that is all i can leave today though
i will save the rest for the future i
was going to say i definitely do
remember these masks from my childhood
it's got to be said
yeah so me too
my favorite is black laby brotherhood
they're also in the original story
and you know poor black levite holding a
coffin on their shoulders
they're uh in leisure p they are not
just rabbits they are future warriors
uh
they are still carrying or coughing and
always trying to skid you into it
i really want to see how you guys
survive when they're hunting
so
in order to go up against them i have
seen from the trailer so far that there
are some ridiculous weapons and you can
even take some enemies to the wood shop
with them if i saw that correctly um so
talk us through the combat we can expect
from liza p and how similar is it to the
souls like games we've been seeing
recently
um i can confidently say the elijah p is
full of unique and one-of-a-kind better
system
and the first system i'd like to talk
about is the weapon combination style
weapons are divided into two parts the
blade and the handle and can be combined
in countless ways each blade and the
handle have their own weight motions
pictures and special skills called
forever arch okay so players are free to
mix and match and create the perfect
weapon for them
it should be fun to try out
outdoor the hundreds of possible
combinations wow
and another unique system in lajo p is
the legion arm system which probably
already shown on the main characters of
left arm yep yep he has a
actually valuable perfect yeah so it's
possible to modify it with the parts and
use special skills
they are particularly flesh and dynamic
and can also be strengthened
i'll be found to choose the right
political amount for the situation you
are here now i had a chance to play it
earlier by the way i'm just going to say
and it is so so difficult so i just want
to let anyone know out there that this
game is so difficult you are going to
absolutely love it but to answer the
elephant in the room obviously the
original pinocchio game had a big
emphasis on his nose growing with every
single lie so i have to ask does this
element of the pinocchio story play into
liza p at all
yeah
first of all i think that uh lying is
the most important aspect of the
original story
and when you really think about it
humans are capable of lying and there
can also be food for their humanity
this also means that we approach the
concept of life in a completely
different way than the original
think about it is there any more than a
more human than using lies to achieve
something yeah we think that in order to
become real human one has to lie and
that is reflected in the game by players
are experiencing a vital event by line
the choices they make will also affect
amber yeah as for what this might do to
his nose
um i can support it for you
you need to find it up for yourself
but i can guarantee you're not expecting
anything
i tell you what when the full game comes
out then the first thing i'm testing is
the lying
yeah
in the game you can lie if you you'll be
a human
but always remember like levi brothers
is always looking for a chance for all
liars entered coffin
right okay moving swiftly onwards from
that then um there had to be a ton of
people putting a lot of time into lysap
to uh pull the strings pun intended to
get a game like this off the ground so
can you talk about the development
process and were there any difficulties
actually getting people to buy into this
reimagining
actually in korea the majority of games
are online keys and mobile games
so there aren't many developers with
expertise in single players games for
consoles okay
so we did a lot of trial and error and
made a lot of mistakes but this was
unavoidable yeah despite
these challenging circumstances the fact
that our team not yeah
has a lot of developers who already have
the experience with the console game
project was a major help yeah most of
all our team absolutely loves console
games so it was easy to get everyone on
board with our obedience for larger p
yeah i would like to give all the credit
to our team members and
they are the reason why elijah p could
come this far yeah and i'm really really
proud of our team and i'm sure they are
so proud of you both sat here today
representing the game as well so shout
out to youtube yeah
yeah it is the first time for us to make
a single player game we all have a lot
of experiences on developing
action games but only limited to all
nine games
at first i was thinking that
making single player games would be
easier
in terms of technical perspective like
no networking
issues etc
but it didn't take long that i realized
i underestimated
yeah our game needed a lot of pictures
we haven't even imagined when you
develop online games okay we only have
one playable character which is which is
easier to make because online games
normally have more than five
very tricky but this one flap character
i mean pinocchio
requires i guess you know
10 times more animation than the online
game makes sense so yeah pinocchio use a
lot of different types of weapons and
each weapon requires
total unique unique animation um
yeah color cell music that's a
total unique set of animation
so i have i have to admit i our initial
plan was
offered in terms of estimating the
the cost of
animations yeah
so if we look at our studio
and probably you can see our animated
artists and combat designers hearing
each other
and arguing all the time we are still in
this chaos but anyway we are enjoying it
and
definitely we'll be better at planning
it next time well i really appreciate
that you brought the chaos to us here in
germany but before we run out of time i
do want to give you to the floor to
share anything you want with everyone
out there about liza pease before its
release
actually
we didn't expect a large appeal to get
this much interest and love from gamers
we really really want to thank you all
for the tremendous level of support
and we do our absolute best and are sure
that you'll be mesmerized by the city of
city of cards
and take care and
see you in the
xbox game pass next year oh yeah
yeah for everybody at gamescom don't
forget to visit our booth and play the
demo
enjoy
and please share your experiences with
us
thank you for having us today and enjoy
gamescom with lies of tea
guys thanks again so much for joining me
but now dancing robots creepy crashes
dummies and theme park rides you really
don't want to visit are just some of the
trippy treats crammed into this
wonderfully weird next trailer set in an
ultimate or alternate 1955 where robotic
technology has grown nail-bitingly
powerful it's up to one rogue agent to
take a stand for humanity and if he
doesn't
well let's just say that's not good for
anybody this is a brand new look at
atomic heart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey welcome back everyone i'm here with
steven takowski from 505 games to talk
about all the gunfire reborn wildness we
just saw in that trailer before its
console cloud and pc release on game
pass on october 27th stephen thank you
for joining us thank you for having me i
really appreciate the opportunity listen
no problem at all we appreciate it and
welcome to gamescom
thank you i mean i'm having a great time
good to be back right absolutely good
okay so gunfire reborn's been around for
a little while now right it's coming to
xbox console and cloud
for the very first time just great news
so give us an introduction to the game
sure so gunfire reborn is a level based
uh adventure game with fps
roguelike and
rpg elements and you pretty much play
with several characters who will have
various abilities
and you will
go on adventures through four different
uh environments and in those
environments there's unique levels
enemies and bosses great okay you can
see from the footage there it's super
bright super colorful super fast now
it's a roguelite as well right so
i'm right in thinking that every time
you start a new run it's going to be a
different experience yeah sure yeah it's
a true roguelike
each route is going to be different each
time you play so it'll always be
different from one game play to the next
uh you don't know what drops you're
getting so you have to adjust to your
environment because you really don't
know what you're going to have and
but you know along the way you're gonna
find different weapons you're gonna find
weapon inscriptions which are you know
different rarities of weapons and uh you
don't know what to expect but you know
you just gotta be prepared and uh you
know you'll know there's gonna be a boss
at the end of each level right which is
your typical roguelike experience but uh
yeah that's pretty much it excellent and
then so from the trailer as well you can
play solo and you can play co-op
multiplayer which is awesome but let's
talk about solo first right what is that
roguelite gunfire reborn experience if
you're just playing on your own well the
solo experience is great you know a lot
of games you want to play roguelike with
like friends this one plays solo it's
the best way to level up your character
unlock new characters and upgrade your
character so soul experience is more
like an rpg
and uh you know there's four
environments that you have to go through
it could be challenging because you only
get one revive for the entire experience
right and so in solo play you're
essentially yeah as you say you're
leveling up you're unlocking new
characters you're working on your
profile basically to then take it to
multiplayer is that right that's correct
and you know multiplayer is
super fun with gunfire reborn uh you can
play four player co-op and it's just a
great experience it's such you know
clean combat um it's really exciting to
see it on you know xbox game pass
because you go you play with your
friends on xbox and
it's just really smooth
combat and uh you know you really learn
to play with your friends you have to
have unique strategies with your friends
and you know everyone picks a hero based
on uh how you want to go into it but you
don't know what you're going to get you
know what weapons you're going to have
and so you do have to adjust on the fly
even with a group of friends excellent i
love that let's talk about those heroes
then i think we got a sense of them from
the trailer right we've got a really
colorful cast of of animal heroes yeah
talk us through them and pick out your
favorite for us as well sure so we have
a cat we have a dog uh you know we have
a bird we have a snow leopard
we have a rabbit we have a turtle they
all have their unique abilities and
perks um you know some of them are
optimal for like elemental damage some
of them are great for delivering you
know melee damage or crits so you know
you do have to spend some time i mean
the the game has a lot there so if you
want to spend the time and drill down
and learn the game you will be rewarded
it's an excellent game that you can
really spend like hundreds of hours on
and we have a massive community online
who really appreciate it you see guides
everywhere on your optimal builds you'll
see tier lists for everything and it's
just a really popular game and you have
to decide which hero is best for you um
you know for me you know i would say
getting started the crown prince is a
very well balanced character definitely
recommended uh you know any weapon he
can use and uh you know he does
corrosive damage with his bomb uh which
is really important and then you know
you have uh you know each character
has an optimal strategy you just got to
decide which one is best for you nice
okay you mentioned the community i want
to come back to that because there is
this incredible community already built
around gunfire reborn so you know want
to give them a shout out and come back
to them but speaking of animals you know
yeah you've got the animal heroes i
think i also saw an animal being used as
a weapon right like a lizard as a weapon
yeah that's called justice and you know
very creative weapons you know
there's a whole arsenal there's eight
different classes of weapons to choose
from you know you could be short-ranged
you've got your shotgun long-range
sniper um you know you have to decide
what do you want to do pistol do you
want to use melee and based on your
strategy based on your class you know
your hero you can decide and but it's
roguelike so each game you don't know
what you're getting but you have choices
you know there's generally three choices
unless you know a boss drops you know an
item for you then you have to pick up
that weapon or you can choose not to
pick up that weapon and you could also
refund the weapons as well so you know
you have a lot of options for your game
play and
you look at the stats on each of these
weapons and
it you have to do your research and
you'll be rewarded for a game like this
i love it all right so we've talked
about the heroes a bit about the weapons
i need to know about these villains as
well who are we up against in gunfire
reborn sure so uh in and you know
enemies in gunfire there's three classes
you know you have your standard enemies
um you know you defeat them you get soul
essence you get copper uh you have your
elite enemies that you find in like
bulbs which are these like hidden cracks
throughout the levels that you can get
some pretty sweet rewards from uh
whether it's like a weapon or a goblet
or a scroll and then you have the bosses
at the end of the levels and usually
you'll get like a legendary scroll two
weapons you know goblet uh soul essence
and copper and uh you know those bosses
definitely can be challenging at first
but once you play the game and get used
to it um you realize they all have a
strategy to defeat um you know some
people we've seen they jump into it they
can be a little bit challenging but you
know after you really do a little bit of
research they become much easier and
it's just all fun yeah
that's one of the things i've
experienced playing you know in my early
runs i was really getting rinsed by the
bosses but you know as you go through
and through roguelike style level up you
get it you work out you know some of the
bosses are huge right i mean i caught
sight a couple in the trailer there oh
yeah they're huge but you know as you
win and you gather soul essence and you
level up your character right it just
gets easier from there yeah and
especially when you're playing with your
friends and co-op as well and you can
bring all that fire to failure
all right yeah we talked about the
community you mentioned them earlier
huge community already in place for
gunfire reborn community keeps coming
back for more um how are you working
with that community and that fan base to
develop the game and you know what can
we expect in the future for gunfire sure
so we're always listening to the
community you know people write guides
and make videos and the game is
constantly getting balanced in order to
deliver an amazing experience like i
said there's millions of players already
in the community who are really enjoying
it and you know we pay attention to them
you know we do have a lot of content
that's coming we'll be announcing soon
um but you know we take in community
feedback in order to create an optimal
experience because we want them to keep
playing i love it love it so i guess the
gunfire reborn community is going to be
a great place for xbox players
to start when they start playing but
given that you know this whole new xbox
community is coming to the game both on
console and cloud and pc through game
pass you know what do you um
how would you sort of say to them why
should they jump into game fighter
sure so it definitely has amazing
replayability it's very accessible you
know if you're a roguelike fan or you're
brand new to roguelites it's great
experience very very clean combat
it doesn't take too long to pick up it
takes a while to master but you can just
jump into it have a great experience if
you have three friends standing by ready
to play
it's the perfect co-op game to have a
great time and you'll spend endless
hours with your friend and you get to
you know have animal creatures that
you're
taking control of and it's it's just a
cool experience so uh yeah great steven
thank you so much i'm so excited to play
and it feels like one of those games you
can get together with your friends of
all ages and just have a total blast
well thank you so much for having me
grammar stephen it's been a pleasure
really appreciate it um okay so there's
nothing quite like gamescom
and it turns out you've all missed this
incredibly special event just as much as
i have so here's a glimpse of what this
brilliant show means to the xbox family
all over the world
what i love about gamescom is the fact
that this is bigger than even this is an
opportunity for all of us from the whole
world to meet each other to play
together to have fun
this is a chance to meet the people who
shares with your passion for the gaming
also you can buy stuff that will remind
you one day yeah this year i've been on
gamescom
so looking forward to be there again
and i'm so excited to have a chance to
meet you all
see you
for me gamescom is not only the expo but
most of all it's huge gaming
celebrations opportunity to meet the
people meet their gamers meet their fans
from around the world is really special
and i think that everyone who has
opportunities should go to the cologne
at least once
for gamescom i'm most looking forward to
meeting some new friends as well as
being reunited with some old xbox family
that i haven't seen in so long in person
so i can't wait to see and hang out with
everybody all in the name of games it's
gonna be fun one memory of gamescom that
i will never forget is the 2018 fan fest
boat party that they threw it's a really
cool place to meet other xbox fans but
also it was the first time i ever met
graham and i'll never forget it because
he and i clearly have great fashion
taste because we were wearing the exact
same shoes to the party
bonjour from friends what i like the
most about gamescom is discovering the
work of the talented teams working on
the tomorrow's games discovering new
worlds new stories and especially
talking with fan about our favorite
games enjoy the gamescom
[Music]
2022 i am joined by mikey and maddie
from scratch games who are here to give
us an exclusive look at high on live
thank you so much both for joining us
and i'm sure the fans are going to be
super excited about this segment because
you have a tons of gameplay to show us
and i want to see it definitely but
before we jump into that could you give
us like a quick overview of what high on
live means
yeah so high on life is the new game
from justin royland studios watch games
uh it takes place it starts out on earth
you're kind of an aimless teenager you
don't really know where you're going
with your life aliens show up they
discover that humans are the best drugs
in the universe and you pair up with a
talking gun that you find to sort of
stop them from ending your species
basically
so yeah we're going to be seeing a bit
of content from the intro tutorial level
to start um you know some fast forward
sort of through here but it's just
because we can only fit so much in this
segment
so and is that like the typical game
from scratch games you would have
yeah so we kind of we kind of have weird
games like if you know we kind of found
each other we like making weird stuff we
all love comedy we all love weird sci-fi
so
it really is right in our wheelhouse
it's just a leveled up version of things
we've done in the past
amazing so i would say let's just jump
right into the gameplay right because
what people want to see sounds great
[Music]
nice house you got
real ritzy way better than my bench oh
wow you really made yourself at home huh
oh there you are who's this weirdo and
why is he setting up a
huge alien computer in our living room
okay
first of all that alien computer is a
very expensive and surprisingly
operational bounty 5000 so uh you're
welcome what five thousand
i've got just the thing a small time
local gangster by the name of nine torg
she took my favorite knife she's got an
operation out in the slums
maybe you kill her and get my knife back
then we'll talk maybe take you out to
glumpies to celebrate all right so we we
just head out to the slums no [ __ ] you
gotta use the bounty 5000 to initiate a
bounty that's what i went through all
the trouble of setting it up for
[Music]
my knife we're looking for the gateway
to the slums i guess looking it
shouldn't be too far listen just follow
the way so i just noticed um it's a
little forward like
is that the usual demo is that a
cockroach uh yeah are you talking about
fast forward yeah yeah so we we're
actually showing the full demo here to
pass behind closed doors but for the
purposes of this video we're just sort
of fast forwarding to make time i
understand and the family was at my
house where do i live in there is that
my family yeah yeah so uh early on in
the game kenny gives you the ability to
teleport your entire house to escape
from the cartel so when you teleport
your house your sister's in the house so
you kind of bring her with you
and she's not too happy about that at
first
and the other guy you see in there
that's gene he's a legendary bounty
hunter at least he was a legendary
bounty hunter kind of fell on hard times
and he's homeless and he sees this
opportunity as a way to sort of get your
house so he's like i'll train you if you
let me crash on your couch if you die i
get to keep the house basically and so
he's really in the beginning he's really
hoping you die i understood
yeah the house is sort of your main hub
and then you have the rest of bloom city
for sci content nbc's lots of good stuff
[Music]
well well
look what we got here fresh meat hey
there fresh meat welcome to the slums
fresh meat
oh boy here we go
kid what's wrong fresh meat you scared
of a little kid yeah the little kid look
at me look at me
i'm sorry this kid is this is annoying
what's this all about well honestly he's
just supposed to be annoying basically
so we implemented this
patented squanch shove tech basically
where characters get in your face and
push you around it's such a funny little
mechanic and he's one of the first
characters you encounter that's doing
this to you and he's really pressuring
you to shoot him but you don't have to
you can skip it yeah
yeah you meet uh his mom later and he's
actually 30s uh okay okay so not really
technically you're not killing that and
it's your choice
[Music]
hey you can't pass through here it's
nine towards term jesus enough with
everyone getting in our way we just want
to kill nine torg yeah right you killed
nine torque get lost
so this is exciting we're in our first
combat um yeah who are we fighting in
this
kenny's primary ability
yeah so this is the first time you're
really getting to use kenny and these
aren't the main enemies you're fighting
these are sort of a lower level set of
goons
and they actually think they're the
strongest enemies in the game but they
find out by the end of this mission that
they're really not and they're just the
ones in the first level it's really
funny it's a really funny sequence and
for kenny you're seeing basically his
primary fire right now this is early in
the game so you're learning how to use
them but throughout the game he'll get
alternate abilities each gun kind of has
three modes one of them is always going
to affect traversal and then on top of
that there's mods for each gun
oh hey you want to see a cool party
trick i used to do amy at those spinny
platforms come on come on give it a shot
it'll be fun
yeah i told you did you see how fun that
was i call it my glob shot it comes out
of my trick hole okay
i'm afraid to ask this question what is
a trick hole is that just america i'm
sorry i thought that was worldwide
but apparently not
so all the guns in the game have three
separate uh abilities so primary
secondary as we mentioned and then
there's an ability fire what you're
seeing here can be used in combat but it
can also be used to open up new
traversal areas and each gun in the game
will sort of open up new areas you can
go back to areas that you were before
and kind of explore find um you know
content collectibles and also get new
npc interactions
yeah we're really trying to push that
light metroidvania feel so the levels
are really dense
you i'm sick of this i want to tear
through someone's guts oh i think
they're talking about gene tonight [ __ ]
you got it freak we've had enough of
your bullsh yeah it's your fault
stepulax is dead i was in love with him
did you know that i loved him and now
his hands come just the way it should be
[ __ ] him hey guess what i have another
secret trick you can use the power of
negotiation let's try reasoning with
these guys knock on the door tell me how
you play you insufferable
when i'm loose oh
who's there who are you uh hey hello
there friends oh i i think it's the
buyer hey are you the buyer
no i'm just here to do my laundry it's
even clean i just i'm a laundry head
can't stop washing stuff over here this
room's off limits everything you need is
in the front get out of here good luck
with your laundry
i mean i have a ton of laundry at home
especially after gamescom but i noticed
there's a lot of dialogue in this thing
can you tell us a little bit about that
yeah so we actually started out kind of
writing out a big dialogue tree our head
writer alec robin's amazing writer and
kind of makes twine games in his spare
time so we had it down
and then once people got in the booth we
kind of encouraged a little bit of
improv to keep things fresh and funny
and then all of that amounts to
basically a huge selection of dialogue
choices and so you just heard him
talking about his ex-lovers nebula
if you knock on the door before that you
don't even have a chance to give that
answer because you don't know that
information so there's a lot of stuff
like that throughout the game that that
you're kind of opting into without even
knowing
nice job they told us this fire was a
real prankster oh you come on that was
pretty [ __ ] up that joke is gonna [ __ ]
me up
you got him good okay though but enough
of that uh let's show them the product
all right here's the product a genuine
talking knife i gotta be honest with you
he's a real piece of he's extremely
violent he basically only talks about
wanting to kill people in very
disturbing ways you i'm gonna carve out
your cavity gonna make it three times as
big your it's just gonna drop right out
of there let's see what i'm talking
about oh a perfect that's exactly what
we're looking for yeah yeah great go
ahead feel free to inspect it try him
out see how he feels in your hand yeah
yeah free me let's go let's go psycho on
these
actually you want to just swing out the
air a bit like far away from us yeah
thanks
come on what are you oh [ __ ] yes thank
you pleased to meet you i'm knifey now
use me use me let me stop these [ __ ]
heads oh just a reminder uh don't do
anything crazy when you're holding the
knife just like look at it see if you
like it put it back yeah thank you
yes more more i need more stabbing
definitely nine torque but let's put a
pin in the the whole gene thing how do
we get out of here with my tether
ability i'm more than just a knife you
racist i can tether too look up and
latch on
i'm sorry but these lines guys but i
remember i remember nike from the first
trailer and i think for fans he has been
fan favorite from the debut tell me
everything about him yeah so he's by far
my favorite weapon in the game he's
voiced by michael cusack who's awesome
he's so funny um and throughout the game
basically he functions as a knife but
he's there to kind of always pick on you
and say funny stuff he also has this
tether ability which affects traversal
through the levels so once you get them
you can kind of go back and some of the
levels were horizontal now they're more
vertical and there's things you can get
that you couldn't get before yeah it's
pretty cool the night the levels really
open up once you get knifey and there's
a bunch of other traversal abilities you
can use in tandem with him and you also
uh can't open chests until you get
knifey which you'll see right here these
are our lug boxes uh hopefully we'll be
selling plushies of these plushies and
knifey um you know i was gonna have that
side hustle um
so you're actually also getting pretty
close to the end of the level here uh
you're to fight the uh the boss nine
torque because your first bounty uh
you're going to be able to use all of
your abilities that you've learned in
the level together so your primary your
secondary you're going to be tethering
around the air arena and you're also
going to be deflecting with knife so you
put it all together you fight nine
torque
[Music]
come on a minute we're hurting you
that was cool
[Applause]
hey i'm still here you can still use me
if you want
i can deflect attacks did you know that
i'm not just all about stabbing well i'm
mostly all about stabbing and tethering
but i can also deflect attacks
i'll slice my death i'll cut their heads
off
and i'll rip their limbs off and do
everything long enough and cut right
into them i'll cut them [ __ ]
off and eat it you know this slug
matches your toxic personality
[Music]
i'm taking you with me
stay
yeah so actually we're showing this full
playthrough of what is essentially the
first bounty you get so uh we're showing
that behind closed doors to press um
there should be full videos online of
the whole playthrough people to check
out uh and we're just so excited to
finally get into people's hands and see
their reactions it's been a real labor
of love for us in the team amazing well
i can say this is a gloomy globby blast
right but when can people get their
hands on the game so december 13th is
going to come out we're really excited
for everybody to check it out we're
working really hard on it yeah seriously
please check it out like this is really
really a special game to us and we
really hope you guys like it
well mikey maddie i have to say first of
all thank you so much for us
sleeping letting us sleep in your game i
really appreciate it
and yeah thanks for having us at the
show and enjoy the rest of gamescom
thank you thank you so much for having
us
and now we are going to take a look at a
game set in the warhammer 40k universe
so just a little change of pace here i
don't know about you but nothing signals
the end of summer like a good co-op
shooter and just as the darkness starts
creeping in we have the perfect slice of
shootie socializing for you set in the
city of tertium play as one of four
types of recently released prisoners as
a last resort to protect the city it's
time for the rejects to rise this is
dark time
dark tide is a first person co-op game
set in the grim dark future of warhammer
40
a sprawling hive city
on the brink of destruction
you are a reject a convict free to serve
the inquisition in this darkest of hours
[Music]
it is your duty to fight
and
if necessary
die
for the emperor
you can expect no help
no reinforcements
you
are
last line of defense
oh
will rise
ema
hola muni
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
unlikely
[Music]
oh that was nice wasn't it nice little
moment of tranquility there in a midst
all the fun of games cobb how's it going
folks welcome back i am excited to
welcome aaron harness the creative
director and lead game designer at
wishfully to talk about the absolutely
gorgeous planet of lana adam thank you
so much for being here i cannot wait to
talk about how beautiful this game looks
but first of all right give us an intro
to planet elana we just saw the trailer
but what should we expect yeah so planet
of lana is a side-scrolling sci-fi
puzzle adventure right and you play this
young girl called lana and and at your
side you have to have this little cute
creature companion yeah and together you
go out on this epic adventure you know
through the world of this this planet
that's set far away in a galaxy and you
you're going on a mission rescue mission
to try and save lana's big sister that's
been taken away by an invading robot
army yeah
that's the gist of it so super exciting
for everyone attending gamescom here
this year and for you as well personally
i'm sure is that you can actually play
planet atlanta for the first time here
right yeah so excited about that you can
play planet lana here in the xbox booth
as well as in the wonderful booth here
in hall 8 so very excited about that and
this is actually the first time we're
showing the game at two media and so
very excited about that so what's in the
demo like what can we expect from it
yeah so the demo is quite an early part
of the game right so it's actually the
first part where you've just met maui so
it's the first part where you get to
you get to play with her at your side so
it's like an introduction and you can
think of movie kind of like a kind like
a dog so you can tell her to go places
and tell her to stop and follow you
she's really a valuable valuable
companion on this epic journey that you
get to experience in planet lana what
kind of feedback are you getting from
people that play it i mean we've gotten
incredible feedback like yesterday and
today and it's just a big queue over at
the thunderful booth so it's just been
absolutely unreal you know five years in
the making now this game and yesterday
was the first day that we showed it to
two players in media for the first time
so yeah
right let's talk about muay because she
is so cute and i can see her on screen
here just now waking up lana um tell us
about muay and what she brings to the
party
so
muy what she brings to the port as i
said before you know
lana is this like you don't have any
weapons in this game right you're
playing as this 11 year old girl and
this
and this creature companion that you
meet and that you befriend she's quite
agile so she can jump higher than you
and reach places that you cannot and but
you can also like bite off cables and do
things like that push down things for
you to reach and then she also has this
hypnotic ability that you might have
seen in our like game
in the gameplay trailer intro we had
just there so you gain that a little bit
later in the game and that then movie
actually can hypnotize like these weird
creatures that you come across that has
the same like glowing white eyes that
she has and that opens up just the whole
set of you know the possibilities of how
to interact with the creatures of this
world which is a lot of fun yeah great i
played the demo myself and one thing
that really struck me was the way that
movie's abilities kind of you discover
them slowly and they kind of build on
each other and the puzzles become more
complex that must have been a really fun
thing to to work out as you design the
game right yeah and i think it's a super
important thing as well you know we've
been focusing a lot on like having a
good ramp up of the game you know yeah
we want this game to
like reach a really really broad
audience but it's also important you
know in this kind of games where you
have
um logical puzzles because everyone is a
different level and have different
abilities of solving these kind of
puzzles so you know it can't be too easy
because that will get really boring and
can't be too
it can't be frustrating either you have
to you know balance that challenge of of
just right i think so yeah and that that
is a challenge in itself but i think
we've done a really good job did you
ever consider like a co-op mode where
two people can you know play as lana and
movie and solve those puzzles together i
mean a lot of people asked us that like
throughout development but it was a very
conscious creative decision from the
like poor idea from the get-go that we
shouldn't have that because i mean we're
going for this relationship with lana
and movie that you kind of have in real
life with a with a dog like the
relationship with a human and a dog so
and if we would like have another
controller and put that in the hands of
a friend to control mobile you will lose
that kind of magic you know that we feel
because mu is
very much her own creature with her own
personality you know
yeah and i think that really comes
through in the
the relationship you see and hear
between lana and maui it's so like
adorable the way they communicate to
each other like tell us how you like did
that through sound design and through
the the language in the game yeah so
we're telling the story without words
right and that's something we want to do
from from from the beginning but then my
co-director and also the scriptwriter
for the game class ericsson he invented
this language for the inhabitants of
this planet on novo and it's just it
just adds so much it adds that extra
layer of like
a way for the characters to be able to
express emotions you know and also since
lana and movie is constantly
communicating with each other so it's
just uh yeah it's it's details that like
that that i think really makes you know
world building so fun and that's
something that we really focused on in
this game i love it for sure yeah i mean
it's a new language but you totally get
what's happening like the way they talk
to each other communicate their little
chirps
exactly it's a mix of the body language
and the language and everything yeah all
right so we talked about lana and our
faithful companion muay um but tell us
about the overall story here because one
of the things i've noticed you know in
the trailers you've got these really
beautiful contemplative moments but then
some moments with real like drama and
speed and you know these big robots as
well so what's the overall kind of story
you're telling yeah so what you can
expect playing our game is really an
epic story that would unfold over like
five six hours when playing the game and
we're really going for that's what i
think that sets us apart a little bit in
the genre like we're bringing these um
these uh companion-based mechanics but
also we're really focusing on on telling
quite a classical saga this story of
this unlikely hero this 11 year old girl
and muy going through this this
incredible journey through the planet on
this rescue mission to try and save her
sister and you come across so many
environments we have like this old
shipwrecks that's been buried in this
swamp for several hundred years that you
get to explore and you get like pieces
of information that that like the the
players that have like have more
attention to detail will get more out of
the rich like backstory that we've
created for this world and the lore of
the world so that's really exciting and
then and then also all players will get
an answer to why humans are living on
this planet and why the robots have come
and why they've invaded the planet and
so forth so yeah it's really a
classic like epic adventure that you get
to experience experience with a lot of
twists and turns as well that i won't
spoil right now love that and we've got
to talk about the art style it just
looks so special tell me about your
inspirations and how that art style's
evolved over the five years you've been
working on the game i mean there's just
so much inspirations uh i mean i grew up
with games like another world and
flashback and odd world as well and
there's definitely a bit of another
world in the game as you can see and and
then just you know stood you give the
films especially miyazaki's film like
spirited away empony on those and like
modern games like inside
but really it's just like
going for like at the start the game
actually started like with these concept
images of the game that was like
beautifully hand-painted and then going
from that concept art into the game that
you have that we have today was a long
process and a lot of iterations to you
know because we wanted to create that
you know depth and immersion that we
have in the world now but still keeping
this hand-painted style so it's like
this 2.5 d
mix of you know 3d and
and and layering of 2d layers and then
and then we also have put put a lot of
um emphasis on bringing this art style
to life as well so we have this wind
system for example right there are
talented programmers that have created
where we can go from calm to full storm
and it's just you know it's it's it's
it's really we have such a talented team
and it's like it's so fun going to work
every day and get to work with this
talented people and everyone is just
pouring in a lot of love into this
project and making that's what created
the atmosphere that you can see in the
trailers and the demo that you can play
well it really shows and part of the
atmosphere is is the music you know and
you've got someone very special working
on the music scoring the music for the
game can you tell us more about that
yeah so we have takeshi furukawa that's
writing the music for the game and he's
known for creating the music for the
last guardian among other things and
he's just a like a prolific composer and
it's just been unreal to have him on the
project i mean it was very unreal from
the beginning but we just get along so
good creatively and
i mean it's also from the get-go we've
decided you know that we also want like
the sound of this planet to speak its
own language you know and then have
music come in to emphasize
um you know special scenes to like
emphasize emotions and music also plays
like a pivotal part actually both in the
gameplay and in the story so it's just
been so great having him on board and
he's just doing an amazing job i think
thank you now you've also announced that
uh planet elana is coming to game pass
which is amazing news for all of us game
past subscribers um what does that mean
for you as an indie developer especially
with this being your you know your first
title as an indie yeah i mean
it's i i can't emphasize how much that
means to us honestly i mean having the
game on game pass day one it will just
let i mean we're making this game with i
mean we want as much players as possible
to experience the game and having it on
game pass just lowers that barrier entry
of people to experience it so it's just
just amazing and also i just have to say
that xbox is actually played a pivotal
role in the
in the um success that planted lana has
gotten up until this point i mean we got
so much support from xbox and it's just
been really really amazing so very happy
to have that collaboration with you guys
that's amazing to hear listen we're
happy that you're here this is
absolutely incredible it's great to talk
about it um
we're gonna hit game pass day one in
spring 2023 right yes why do we have to
wait so long adam i want to play now
yeah so i mean it was a week a week ago
we announced that we're delaying the
game we were planning originally to have
it released in this year 2022 but i mean
uh it's both both i think it's i mean
this game that we're making it just
needs to be at a very high level of
polish to to really create the the
vision and experience that we want to
create so it's just the right decision
you know i think the place will be happy
in the end that we made the decision not
release the game prematurely yeah i
think that's always a good decision yeah
i know you're quite right something
special deserves
all the time anyway yeah that's great um
right before you go is there anything
else you would like to share with our
audience any highlights from gamescom or
i mean
it's just unreal being here really just
just experiencing all the love and
support that we have gotten from the
game over the years and here at gamescom
and yeah just thanks for for everyone's
support yeah and very happy to be here
adam absolute pleasure okay everyone
that's the gorgeous planet of lana
coming to xbox game pass in spring of
2023 day
one thank you adam for joining us today
and bring in such a beautiful game enjoy
the rest of the week thank you so much
thanks for being here
all right coming up my co-host and pal
charlie will be speaking with shyla
schofield from obsidian entertainment
about the much anticipated release of
grounded 1.0 but before that we've got
even more grounded 1.0 content to share
we're going to hear from phil spencer
himself and the creative director of
grounded adam breneke about what we can
expect from the upcoming release of
everyone's favorite backyard adventure
so what i like most about gamescom is
that i come together with different
people from around the world that i
usually don't really see very often
because we don't live in the same city
or country
and games comes the perfect opportunity
for me to finally meet them and to enjoy
video games to its fullest
what i like the most about
gamescom without a doubt is the close
community atmosphere the best thing is
to be able to see each other again and
enjoy in person side by side what we are
passionate about gaming and video games
and of course it's amazing to be part of
it and enjoy everything that xbox has
prepared for this event thank you and
enjoy the gamescom hi everyone i have
been at gamescom twice one is a
journalist about 10 years ago and one
with the xbox team in 2019 and it has
always been very special for me i had so
much fun there and i think it's really
great to have in europe a big gaming
moment like gamescom where gamers can
meet and enjoy video games together
as well as discover new titles or even
make new friends
this year i will not be able to attend
but i cannot wait to see what's
announced at gamescom and hope everybody
enjoy it
my favorite thing to do at gamescom is
to be just outside of the booth right
when the gates open on saturday morning
and you have this crush of people you
really start to feel how big gamescom is
because it is like the running of the
bulls but like with more gamers and and
less injuries but it just shows the
dedication and the commitment of gamers
in germany and throughout europe and i'm
definitely missing that this year i miss
gamescom i'm not there this year i miss
walking around the show floor the show
floor is just massive and there's
thousands of people and just seeing what
uh what's new in the games industry
certainly i work in it but seeing it
with other fans is a ton of fun i miss
that i miss xbox fan fest and of course
i miss the curry burst
hey everyone phil spencer here really
excited we're gonna get to talk about
grounded great game a game i love
playing we have adam breneke here from
the team
go ahead and introduce yourself i'm the
game director um and uh thanks so much
for having me i'm super excited to you
know be here finally we're at the end of
the runway for for grounded and it's a
super exciting time yeah i mean you know
grounded is a game we've been playing
what for like a couple years now
uh started in game preview in game pass
i think it's been amazing to see
what over 10 million people have played
the game to date i've played a ton i
love it uh i'm can't wait for the 27th
of september when we get 1.0 ga story
mode all of the great things that are
coming you know to me when i think about
all of the games that we're building
one of the things i really love about
grounded is you find a passionate team
which you lead a passionate team that
has a real creative idea
maybe something that isn't exactly
expected from the studio
but you had a vision about something you
were going to go build
and that we could work together foster
grow that to the point we're at now
where it's getting ready to release i
think it's fantastic it's it's wild to
be like in this position to be able to
make something so creative if this is
the first time you're you're hearing
about grounded or seen grounded grounded
is a survival game and you have to
survive in this backyard environment the
main goal is to get home we're at the
end of our journey of building the game
and with the community and this is the
final update for the full complete yard
it's the biggest update yet right yeah
we have a bunch of cool surprises a lot
of cool new environments that uh you
know are are gonna be uh really fun to
to explore yeah the team's pouring their
hearts into it right now and uh i think
it's it's just been so fun to work
alongside the community too yeah we
built with with uh the early access and
game preview programs so many players
have given us
great feedback along the way it's really
shaped how we developed grounded right
now we're actually uh checking out the
one of the early adventure areas in the
game uh it's the hedge you're shrunk
down to you know the size of an ant yeah
and uh actually i think the ants are
bigger than you are they're a little bit
bigger right yeah
the the players right now are going
through this hedge maze and it's nestled
on the side of the house you're trying
to figure out like how you got here and
how you're going to get home you know
part of the adventure is exploring all
these cool areas and environments of the
yard
one thing that we're really proud of for
our uh final 1.0 release is our story
yeah i think that's one thing that
really separates us from uh
most survival games and we spent a lot
of time world building adding a lot of
characters and storylines to the world
yeah i think there's like for me i
played in game preview game pass
it was great co-op game because we get
together as our friends one of the
fantastic ways to go play build our base
i happen to go visit right around the
xbox bethesda showcase it was fun to
come out to the studio you and i getting
together
got me re-energized so i started i went
back into the game and so much had
changed
and now i'm kind of i'm so waiting for
that story mode the setting because the
story it's a great setting for a story
um kind of have a guided beginning of
the game
and then the sandbox will obviously just
open up yeah yeah for players and uh how
will you deal with like i assume you'll
have some players who will be like me
returning of the 10 million people who
have played when it comes out and then
you have other players who are brand new
where the idea of okay now it's at 1.0
now is when i'm gonna go dive in like
use a team how do you think about those
kind of different players coming and how
do you design for that yeah so i think
the one thing that uh you know we want
to invite all the players that have
tried grounded um you know even two
years ago we want them to come back and
try it again and experience the full
story experience the full yard because
there's so much content in this yard
it's a big open world there's so many
cool environments cool creatures to find
um but i also like for the brand new
player you know it's a survival game
first and foremost but
it's definitely a different twist on a
survival game there's one thing that
we're really proud of is the
accessibility and approachability so um
even just right now we're looking at the
broodmother fight so this is one of our
boss fights in the game where you fight
this giant spider in her spider den it
looks kind of funny because this is we
have a arachnophobia mode yeah yeah and
that's one thing that's really important
to us is uh making the game accessible
for all different types of players we
have tons of game options so even if
survival seems you know that might be a
hardcore genre of game we're trying to
bring in a huge audience with a lot of
options to play the game how you want to
play i think that's really important to
us and we saw that in the community like
certain people just focused on the base
building and building i mean frankly
almost levels are bases that took over
the whole size of the lake which was oh
it's awesome i think you're gonna get a
lot of people
who want story i think the the boss
battles and the kind of
the the circle of collecting items
building up your crew so you can go in
and take down different parts of the
game awesome people build huge
fortresses
it was an enormous amount of time
building these crazy crazy huge forts um
and then
that gave us ideas of adding more yeah
we added mushroom bricks um and
we want to add more building materials
in the future well and that loop that
you're you're commenting on now i don't
think that
it's not always recognized how important
that is is like a team has a vision
that vision meets reality of through
game pass and preview 10 million people
play and continue to play and then
they're going to give you feedback and
that will actually change your
production schedule right because you're
going to listen and watch what people do
yeah even even as simple as like sitting
in chairs i know that was a fun one that
we put in like a year ago yeah um that
was a huge ass just like people just
want to lounge around in their base
right they built this huge just now
yeah it's a chill right one thing for
our uh 1.0 release uh there's a couple
more surprise boss fights that we're
really excited about any hints or no
well we did show off the mantis yeah so
that's something that i know a lot of
players have been asking for for a long
time to fight a brain mantis and
grounded so we are delivering that
experience and uh i'm we got a couple
more uh surprises that's awesome well
congrats to the team on getting to this
point we're not quite there yet 27
september thank you i think for
everybody who's played myself included i
just love the craftsmanship
and passion that clearly the team has in
putting together such an amazing game
that's a great game to play either by
yourself with your friends
can't wait to see it come out and it's
great to be here and get to show people
more of the game so thanks for all of
that thank you
here to continue the conversation on
grounded we have shila scovered with us
from obsidian entertainment to give us
all the backyard dirt on the upcoming
1.0 update which releases on the
september 27th shiloh welcome to the
stream how you feeling being here at
gamescom i am so excited i you know this
is something that i've missed being in
the show floor oh yeah watching players
play the game there's nothing better
than being able to get something that's
been worked on so long and getting
players to watch it so for me this is
thrilling there's a particular energy in
the room today as well yeah they're not
yeah oh no it's great and i think
everybody's just glad to be back and
playing games
out in public again so it's fine i
totally agree right let's move swiftly
onto grounded then as that's what we're
here for so some folks out there might
recognize it as grounded it's been
around and available in game preview for
like two years now thanks to game pass
um and phil mentioned something very
exciting in a deep dive then with adam
and that is that the full story is on
the way so what exactly does this mean
and how is it going to be integrated
into a game that players have grown pun
intended to love so much over the years
without one oh yeah no worries so
there's a few questions that you get
when you start the game and that is why
am i so tiny yes whose backyard is it
and how did i get here
so valid questions right you wake up and
you're tiny you need to know these are
important so with the story that's being
integrated into the current game play
you are going to be able to uncover
these answers find out how you got there
and ultimately hopefully be able to go
big and go home i love that that's the
thing yeah you guys say it's great so
perfect it's the best one
so um a reminder to fans so this is
actually going to be the largest update
that the game has had so far right yes
it's going to be absolutely huge so i
would love for you to highlight some of
both the big and the miniature because
it's grounded uh updates that games uh
that players can expect are coming to
the game perfect so we do have some
things i know adam mentioned the mantis
fight and there was a picture of it um
it is huge it is something that the
players have been asking for
for so long one of the most requested
insects so the fact that we could put
that in and players will finally get to
experience that fight that's perfect i
love the like of all the games that you
could find in germany this week i do
believe yours is the only one where
people have begged to fight a praying
mantis you know what and if that's the
case that's perfect i love it
so as someone who enjoys the spiders in
it the mantis is the next step
absolutely yeah along with that and like
we mentioned the story will be going in
uh there will be an expansion to the
backyard so there are going to be new
areas for players to explore
obviously new items to craft and
everything else
i wish i could go into specifics but
that's just something that we have a
month away so they could wait absolutely
but there have been so many updates
along the way you mentioned new
locations but it's not the first time
you've done this over the last couple
years no no no so back when we launched
in july of 2020 grounded started and it
was basically an oak tree and there were
some areas that you can go explore but
all your stuff is around this tree over
the years we've expanded to a koi pond
where we have a giant koi fish named
trudy ii
who if you look at her has a scar over
one of her eyes oh okay yes i don't know
why i asked someone once and they just
said
trudy seen some things so we leave it at
that i was gonna say what happened to
trudy one as well that's the only answer
i've got but she lives in the pond
players can meet her after that we went
and we expanded the hedge which is where
the brood mother lives they can go
explore that background get some fun
stuff from there and then we went into
the haze which was originally part of
the official launch
but when we want we wanted to go back
and do it like it was there we were cool
with it but we had so many more other
plans that the team was able to go
through and redo the haze to make it
something that they wanted they added a
sandbox which has a very angry crab face
that i love because one of the first
times you get into it you're zip lining
in and you just go right past this angry
trap so it's perfect there's a picnic
table which has a table top game that
is called minotaurs and myrmidons volume
two obviously yes and so you actually
get to go through the tabletop castle
that they've built because whoever lived
there left some miniatures and
everything playing around so cool and
then the most recent one that they just
added was the upper yard area which
includes a wood pile and the termite den
so not only do you get a knocked over
barbecue pit and you get to go explore
that but now you get to go meet the
termites which are always a blast meet
the termites
so how many updates have you done now
for those who may not have been
following how many are we up to um i
want to save 14 which will be okay 14
will be coming yeah as many of our fans
know we do push out our updates onto a
public test before making them go live
and this is one of the beauties about
being on game preview and working with
our community so the one that will be
coming up hopefully soon because it's
available to test okay will be 14.
however i believe i've done 18 vlogs
so we've been updating for a little
while now absolutely and it's been
amazing to see both the community and
the game itself grow so the lack of that
word momentously over the last couple
years and as well as that received
positive feedback along the side so um
now we're only a month away from the
games for release as phil mentioned on
september 27th yeah i want to know what
that journey has been like for you
personally it's been amazing
it's been great so when we first
announced grounded at xo19
it was a very exciting time it was a
very
you know good anxious time and
everything because grounded is not the
type of game that you go obsidian
that's perfect that's what i'm expecting
and so to bring it to exo and get a
first-hand glimpse at not only the
announcement but players actually
playing it for the first time
that was just great and so to see it go
from those few who are at that
convention grow to 1 million in the
first 48 hours
5 million in the first oh yeah and then
recently we hit 10 million
watch this grow and to watch the team
work with the community to build this
game uh
it's impressive like it makes me happy
every time i think about it i'm just so
proud of what this game has become to
not just the team but the community and
players oh absolutely and talking about
a whole 10 million of those players i
got to say you must get a ton of
feedback and a lot of requests so
two-part question here number one how on
earth do you go through all of that and
work through all the feedback yes so our
team is very dedicated to knowing what
the community wants and so when i say
they read everything
they read everything oh everything is
right everything they are on the reddit
constantly seeing what players are
posting what kind of faces or
information that they're sharing with
others they are on our discord seeing
what's being talked about there twitter
facebook any place that people are
talking about grounded streams
they're there to see what ideas people
are suggesting and what they can put
into the game and so in order to have
that and have a way that we can parse
through everything we have an official
discord where we encourage players to go
and join the discord and join the
suggestion channel that's a great idea
it is and it's very what's nice is it's
very community focused type of way of
getting suggestions in because they can
go and suggest something and then the
community can vote so if it's something
people really want they can vote it up
if it's not something that they really
care about they could just leave it
alone and once these suggestions reach a
certain limitation then they're put onto
an excel file and then they're brought
in front of the game director and the qa
lead and our community manager and
player support specialist bless our
hearts they go through everything with
them and they make sure that the
community is being heard in front of the
dev team fantastic so my follow-up
question on that then is i'd love to
know how the community is actually
shaped grounded over the years and if
you can give any in-game examples that
actually only exist because people have
shouted so loud about it yes so one of
the ones like adam mentioned sitting
like well yeah we saw it just then in
that clip who knows sitting is what
people want in their games right but it
makes sense because we introduced chairs
yep and stuff was and so people were
able to decorate their faces and
decorate them they did but then it would
just be like come to my base
but we can't sit don't you dast it no no
no no no no so we went ahead and we were
able to bring sitting to the game and so
now people can lounge around that was
one thing that without the community
like
without how often they requested it yeah
wouldn't probably be possible lotteries
are another one because people are
building giant houses they're building
bases um we've seen bases take over the
entire yard and sometimes they build
straight up they don't want to spend
their time at climbing a spiral
staircase so they started suggesting
ladders
and we did it
a lot of the suggestions that we take
from them which are great are quality of
life suggestions yes yeah because
they're playing the game they know what
they want in order to make the game more
fun for everyone
and so a lot of the stuff that we've
seen come from them that help are the
ability to auto pick up arrows when you
know you're going to shoot i miss stuff
all the time the arrows fly around the
ground instead of having to go one by
one and pick them up you can actually go
and just walk over them and they're
yours saved you a click i would call
that the definition of quality of life
when it comes to a game as well love to
hear it
perfect perfect
i am curious though what do you think is
the most unexpected addition to the game
that you've seen so far oh so the most
unexpected and probably one of my
favorites
um so we're talking about quality of
life and i see this as a quality of life
others may disagree
but uh one of the suggestions was an
infected wolf spider
people asked for that oh yes okay sure
back when we announced the haze and we
revamped it and everything else uh we
reintroduced new uh new creatures in the
yard such as the infected weevil
everybody loves the weevil yeah this
one's better because it explodes and
there's not nothing more fun than that
oh absolutely not
and then we also have larva infected
larvae and their whole goal is just to
ruin your day and they're perfect i
relate strongly to that i won't lie
they're perfect they're my little babies
i love them but
we didn't have a spider in there at
first so they started asking for this
infected wolf spider and lo and behold
we have one now there you go i guess if
you want that then go for it um one last
quality live check i'm gonna go before
we move onwards um i'm sure many people
out there like myself and watching the
stream are incredibly proud of the
builds that they've been making over the
past couple years so um i just want to
double check with you can you put our
minds to ease that when 1.0 finally
releases we don't need to say goodbye to
all that hard work yeah no so the team
is very dedicated with every update that
they do
to make sure all the hard work all our
players put into the game is safe
amazing obviously there are going to be
some things that we may not be able to
find because it is in game preview early
access uh-huh but that is our number one
goal today intention is to make sure
that is yes yes and so they are doing
everything that they can to make sure
that when this goes up everything can go
through your base will still be there
yeah that said i would like to say that
they would love to see people start a
new save just to experience grounded
with the story yeah from the beginning
so start over you know
learn about the baby save yes yes
exactly yeah yeah because you can keep
your other ones don't delete the other
ones
keep it there no no no let's start a new
one and that way you can experience it
and then you'll be able to experience it
because there are a lot of players who
have been playing from day one yeah the
team has been able to make a lot of
changes to the beginning of the game to
where if they haven't started a game in
a few months it's completely different
yeah and that's one of the things that i
love about being here is that we're
talking to players and i'm finding some
who
haven't played in months they they were
just like i'm done i picked it up a few
months later and they were like oh my
god there's so many changes this is and
they've just been hooked because now
they they find some ease in this
situation that feeling of survival has
come back again right i imagine i mean i
don't have a words in people's mouth but
for the people who are
end game building they're in their
massive mansions they've got every every
material possible when story mode comes
along they're going to be able to dive
right in and they're fully prepared so
it's whether or not people want to
really go back to those roots and that
survival and get themselves from the
ground well grounded up again i suppose
and the thing about this story too is
when this update does come out
the story is going to be integrated into
the game so it's not going to be a
separate mode like they're not going to
go through and pick new game story mode
yeah it's just going to be in the game
like quests and everything else
so people who have been playing will
also be able to join the story mode
without having to do any any fancy stuff
to get it to work fantastic and while
we're talking about stories you know i
have to do this so i'm so sorry
charlotte can you give us a little
foreshadowing on the full story that
players will unlock in version one you
know what i really wish i could but i
know omnipracticals technology is
watching and i just
will leave it at that
that's fine you've got to try you've got
to try what i will do instead is i'm
going to jump over to the topping on
everyone's lips which is the brood
mother
we saw her in the footage just then with
adam and phil she's literally right here
behind me i can see she's absolutely
stunning and we saw some of the epic
battle gameplay with said mother um and
i'm just gonna make some estimations
here is that a final boss battle is
raiding on the way can you tell us a bit
more about combat i'm so curious yes um
i love that you
just automatically go to a final boss
because she's humongous she is surely
the mother is the end of the game no she
is actually the first mini boss player
is going to encounter that says a lot
about where it's going as well yes it's
great um so fun fact when we first
launched the game there was a spider
that lived on a flying disc man
in the hedge yeah and that was her home
players would go and disrupt her and
she's just living about launching
and so the dev team decided to take her
out for a bit yeah they built her a
beautiful home and now for the price of
the blt
lt blt uh bombardier parts ladybug parts
and thistles so not a bacon lettuce
tomato yeah
love but you go and you build that
sandwich you present it to her little
cove and then she comes out and she goes
oh thank you for the food oh and your
dessert so you get to get to experience
a little bit about that yeah so tell us
a bit more about the combat then so i'm
approaching it from someone who when i
raid i'm very much like a ranged melee
type but i like to surround myself with
tanks dps healers etc is this the type
of combat you can see folks taking in
that level of strategy also to a degree
is there solo combat do you think you
could take on the broodmother by
yourself yes so the one nice thing is
although we don't say like
you could be this class's gossip and all
of the kids in the game
they are built the same the way that we
get to that and allow you to kind of
customize your game is that we have
mutations in the game oh okay and that
is something that you can pick so like
for the broodmother there's a mutation
called a reliable friend
and for people playing with me that is
probably the best mutation to have to
play dialogue okay i just like to go in
and charge and be like hey friend no no
you're not my friend
and so with a reliable friend they're
able to uh pick someone up much quicker
so you can get back into the fight
because there are babies and ads that
come in
and um that could be pretty hard to pick
someone up as you're being picked at by
a few different spiders yeah no that
makes sense so there is a way to do it
with friends yeah and get yourself ready
get all the equipment already in fact is
there any gear that maybe like you've
eyed up because we were talking just
before we were saying here and uh you
actually were doing that game play in
the background of phil and adam's
conversation so as someone who's taken
on the broodmother themselves what's
your number one tip that you could give
us maybe to prep and think about my
number one tip is that um like most
people know spiders are afraid of fire
and so if you get some spicy stuff on
your weapon uh spicy spicy so we have um
different modes so you can collect mints
and collect uh
transmute your weapons that way and
stuff my favorite is the spicy which
adds a burning effect to it and
spiders do not take well to that so that
is probably the best weapon you can have
okay for a range player like you we do
have arrows that are equipped with the
spicy tip so that way you can use that
to fight and you'll be good perfect and
then i can just run around the map pick
them all up again yup give your view off
i go again you're great stunning i love
this right um the one thing that is
really amazing about grounded in
particular um is the fact that we could
talk about the full release is coming in
a month as a reminder september 27th but
like i said the amazing thing is that
you can go play it right now yes right
this second so um i want to ask you for
both new and returning fans reminds
people where they can go play grounded
right now yes so grounded is currently
available on xbox game pass which i do
say i subscribe to and it is i call it
the subscription worth subscribing to i
call it theft so i'm glad we have
different words for it you know but we
mean the same thing it is we really do
the value is phenomenal and uh the fact
that there are so many day one games
just like grounded yep
so many of the shows we have uh the
games even we spoke about today as well
oh no it's great so that is like the
easiest way that i recommend people
because then if they're done with
grounded there's so many other games
that they can go and explore absolutely
that's perfectly fine we're all gamers
we all want to see what's out there
if they don't want to do xbox and fast
it is currently available on the windows
store and on steam so you could purchase
it now yeah this is the early access
game preview price
we have announced that the price will be
going up sure so for people who are
waiting for story mode before they
actually go out and play yeah i would
suggest if you want to own it buy it now
take advantage of this price otherwise
xbox
let's talk a little bit gamepl about the
booth itself as i mentioned we do have
this amazing photo up uh behind me with
the broodmother i'd love you to tell us
a little bit about why that's here and
why it's so important to the team to
turn up in that way oh yeah no it's just
it's great for us because we get to
bring a piece of the game for players to
actually experience the beautiful thing
about the brood mother is that she's
built to scale two scales two scales so
she is 17 feet wide seven and a half
feet tall
and thankfully we have her in a hunched
mode so she's not completely towering
over you
but it's just amazing to
have that and have that fan experience
here especially when we have an update
coming out very soon that players can go
and experience it's nice to bring them
here say hey check out grounded and then
when the update comes out they can go
and they can play with their friends and
that is something that i do want to
mention that we do with this update we
have something else that players have
been asking for and although it's not
out in the public it's out on the test
flight okay and that is shared worlds
okay interesting so and that means so if
you and i want to play a game
we will by the way yes yes and you're
like you know what i have stuff to do
and i'm like you know i i want to keep
playing you can share your world with me
you log off you leave and then i can
pick up from by playing myself and then
when you come back on it you join my
game and all the progress i've made is
saved and it's just a way that the team
has been able to get players to continue
to play with their friends
and keep that momentum going because
when you get on a roll like in a
survival game and you're like we're
building this house yes and someone
leaves you're like okay i hope i can
remember what i want to get back yeah
absolutely and i think that rolls into
the whole theme we've spoke about it
fair bit but the accessibility of the
game yes and i think again we saw the
broodmother is another element that is
brought into accessibility and there's a
keyword for it you told me about it and
i would love for you to say the word
yourself of what this is the danger
numbering
so back in the day back in the wee days
when it first came out
we do have accessibility mode and that
is something that came about because
we're able to work so close with xbox
and their teams and so they worked
greatly to figure out
why people you know have arachnophobia
what kind of triggers them and stuff
there's loads of research into it right
yeah so and we wanted to find a way in
order to get this mode playable so that
way fans could play the game who are
afraid of spiders but also still felt
like they were getting the true
experience sure and so back in the day
we called it it's still called
arachnophobia mode and everything but we
started to see some people here there
call it a danger dumpling
and it just kind of sucks so internally
that is our name
so we we love it uh some people find it
more frightening than the one with the
legs to each their own
i personally love the one with the legs
but the danger dumpling mode is also
perfectly fine just a big spider gal on
oh it's great
at some point i'll have a tarantula but
we're waiting on that i love the goal
man i think the spider is going to
happen it's happening absolutely well i
know i need to get a picture with this
laugh so if someone could just
screenshot this
right here then maybe i've already done
it today um but i did want to thank you
so much for joining us today shiloh it's
been an absolute pleasure talking to you
um and i hope you enjoyed the rest of
the boots at gamescom though i have a
feeling they're not as spider-infested
as you want them to be so thanks again
my darling yes thanks for having me here
you're more than welcome so now that
we've explored the backyard coming up
we'll be taking a trip back in time to
the 16th century to when my co-host maxi
chats with the folks behind pentiment
the upcoming murder mystery adventure
game set in bavaria in the 1500s but
first we have a video to share that
might strike a little bit of a cord
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so joining us now our game director josh
sawyer and our director hannah kennedy
to talk to us about obsidian's medieval
narrative game pentamin because the game
is set in bavaria i can finally bring
out my inner bavarian and say it
nice to have you thank you so much for
joining us here thank you for having us
yeah thank you and i also want to call
out that i really appreciate that you
are the only two guests who have set a
game in germany
and
josh
are here to time
so he just gave you a race basically
wonderful no continue
he said he nice to be here but i think
we would appreciate if we stick to
english if you're okay
okay perfectly fine so um
now that
the game is set in bavaria and i'm a
little biased here because i live in
bavaria i've had my share fair of
oktoberfest but i think what's really
interesting
why did you choose that region
um i think my interest in germany goes
all the way back to my childhood
my grandmother was born in kempton on
the southwest part of bavaria and um i
started learning about my family history
and our genealogy when i went on to
college i studied german music later
german history german language uh
continued studying german after i
graduated uh and then so i just had this
interest in german culture and history
and i had an interest kind of in maybe
exploring that
someday through games
so now that we know where the game is
set could you tell us a little bit more
about the the when the who and give us
an overview of what pencilman is about
sure pentiment is a narrative adventure
game and it is set in 16th century
bavaria specifically ober bayern uh in
the fictional
keersaw abbey and the nearby community
of tassing uh kiersaw abbey is a
benedict team double abbey very rare for
the time and also very rare for the time
it's still producing illuminated
manuscripts which by the 16th century
had mostly been taken over by groups
like the guild of saint luke um you play
a character named andreas mahler andreas
is a journeyman artist who is completing
his van der yara or wandering years so
he's been traveling around europe
getting experience working with masters
um but he's making a little bit of money
at keersaw abbey before he returns to
nuremberg and um
a murder happens so that kind of throws
a wrench into things um his friend at
the abbey is accused of the murder and
he basically is the only person in the
position to try to prove that he didn't
do it but he has to figure out who
actually did so andreas mala sounds like
a friendly guy he's gonna save his
friend is that his only like friendly
trade or can we learn a little bit more
about him no so andreas is a specific
character on obsidian is kind of known
usually for making more blank slate or
broad characters but andreas is a
specific character in this place in time
so he comes from a family of artists in
nuremberg hence the name mala uh so
but his father was able to do a
commission for the rector of the
university of erfurt which gave andreas
the opportunity to get a university
education
but he dropped out so he has something
of the university education that allows
you to pick your backgrounds for andreas
um but he eventually goes back to the
artist's life the family business so to
speak um and he's just trying to wrap
things up before he becomes a master
when this kind of throws wrench and
everything
and there are a few games that are set
to play as one character for a 25 year
life lifespan um so i would imagine
andreas as you just described like it's
a pretty interesting character um but
could you tell us
what the fans can expect in the 25-year
journey yeah um i mean i would say again
most most obsidian role-playing games
will focus on a story that takes place
over maybe a few months maybe a year or
so it's pretty rare to have something
that spans decades of time and we really
wanted to focus on seeing how a
character like andreas who
is coming into his adulthood uh
beginning his life as a master how he
changes over several decades but not
only him also kiersaw abby and tassing
which are characters of their own filled
with
actually hundreds of characters um
interconnected families the monks the
nuns the peasants the craftsmen and just
seeing how they change over time
but it also it isn't just narrative it
also has a lot of impact on how we
portray that through the art
yeah so the art is reactive to this time
that passes as well and we really wanted
to make sure that the characters didn't
feel in isolation like they were growing
while everything else was staying the
same so the scenes are updated as well
as people growing and changing over time
some people pass away so that presented
some challenges in that we wanted still
these characters to feel recognizable
like you remember them from previous
acts or they might have been babies or
children or completely different people
um
but still be
easily recognizable and still something
that you can feel attached to as well as
with the scenes you know different scene
states change as well as each of our
acts is set in a different season a
different time of year so we have
updated weather effects the landscape
changes with the time
and so yeah impacted everything we try
to make that as thorough as possible
and i really love how the game like has
set in this medieval look and that you
would see it in kind of i would say
ancient text and how did that period
time and location drive the art style of
the game directly yeah absolutely the
art style was really informed by this
period of time and real existing art
from that period
this is a historical game so
we have the opportunity to be as
representative as possible as well as
this is a story that's being told from
an artist's perspective
so we got to reference works from the
time period both to inform how we wanted
the game to look as well as the key
points of reference for
you know different information about the
characters themselves because this is a
pre-photograph
period of time so you know we looked at
existing art from artists of the period
to inform what people decorated their
homes with what types of things they
cooked
what types of clothing they wore this is
all things that you can find reference
information about through text but
when you're trying to represent how they
look
and you know find ways to adapt that art
into the context of a game it was really
useful to look at paintings um one
example is that andreas mailer is um
designed after specifically the
self-portraits of albert door um
you know that was not only a
painting that showed what our at the
time looked like but also how that
artist viewed himself or at least wanted
to present himself to the world at the
time another really uh core piece that
we used to reference um for building the
scenes themselves was the nuremberg
chronicle that was a really large book
with lots of different woodcuts in it
that showed landscapes and people all
sorts of things so the woodcut style
from that we used that text
really consistently throughout making
the art for the game and you can see
that those details they stand out it's
such a unique approach of the art style
of the game which is really great and
how does that
gameplay work in that environment
yeah so uh learning uh laying out the
scenes based off of that informed a few
different things definitely how the
character navigates the space uh we had
some experiments on what felt good if it
was gonna be sort of open floor plan
navigation versus navigating on paths so
figuring out um how the scenes were
going to be
positioned and how the paths were going
to work definitely informed
how we were going to have the player
navigate the space one example was that
we
had some challenges with
paths going straight up in the game felt
really bad and eventually we kind of
figured out this is because all of the
reference material that we were styling
there after they almost never show a
character head-on they never walk into
the scene space they're always shown in
three-quarter view so identifying that
that's what felt right within the art
style definitely changed the design of
the navigation and the the
locomotion within the game
and one
like definite
style really stands out to me and i
think i saw some tattoos that also have
this type of font josh like what are the
fonts that you that you are using in the
game yeah so fonts are a really big part
of the uh the game and the art that we
wanted to have really custom made and
bespoke for uh what we were doing here
so we worked with a partner studio to
design a number of different
custom fonts for the game and we wanted
them to be different for different types
of people both in different social
classes different cultural backgrounds
we have a peasant script we have a
special font that's just for the monks
um and that process was really important
i think it was josh's kind of idea he
wanted to incorporate this to round out
the characters within the game um but
yeah i think we have six right six
different fonts i think so
yeah and they're um we also put a lot of
effort into custom features for
rendering the fonts so we have all these
different typefaces um
most of them are actually scripts so
they're handwritten and the way that we
convey that we stroke mask every single
character so every stroke of the letter
comes in one at a time and the way it
comes in it comes initially as very dark
glossy ink with a highlight and it
quickly fades and goes into the page and
dries and it bleeds around the edges
additionally people make mistakes and
they actually will make mistakes in real
time and you'll see them scratched out
and redrawn
also even things like we use different
special colors this was all this is
found in a lot of illuminated
manuscripts for example the word god uh
we'll often you'll see a
piece of dialogue written out but god
will be written last in red ink which
was the way that they would do it um and
then finally in other features that are
one printed typeface because this is the
birth of print in this era um that
typeface is actually pressed in so
everything else is written in but the uh
the drucker type is pressed into the
page and it has a procedural void and
bleed effect to represent under and over
inking the the letter forms that
actually press in
i love this details i can talk about
fonts forever i love them yeah
the whole show is going to be france now
for now guys i'm sorry i'm sorry no but
you are making a game you're making sure
that anybody can play that game and it
is accessible could you tell us a little
bit about that feature yeah so i mean
one of the things that we found very
early on is that because of all these
special fonts and also because we have a
game with so much writing um people were
being challenged by a lot of those fonts
yeah uh i mean they were hard they even
made jokes in that time period about
hard how hard to read those those uh
handwriting forms were so we have an
easy read uh
mode so at the beginning of the game or
any time in the game you can say i don't
want the super complicated fancy fonts i
just want the easy read fonts it
replaces everything makes it much easier
to read you can scale all the text up
very large we have a high contrast mode
we also have a text-to-speech option uh
that helps a ton and then there are
other features for like cognitive
challenges or even just if you don't
know anything about history so i think
there are going to be a lot of people
who see this i hope and they say i love
the art style i like the idea of a
narrative adventure but i don't really
know much about germany or 16th century
so we have a glossary in game anytime
you see a term
martin luther who was martin luther
erasmus who is erasmus you'll see it
underlined and you can go into the
margin get a quick definition enough to
understand the context and go back in
that goes into your journal so you can
reference it at any time and then
because we have such a huge cast of
characters um we also found that people
were saying i can't keep all these
people straight so when a character is
not in the scene but they're mentioned
their name is underlined and you can go
into the margin you'll see a picture of
them to go like oh that's brother ghee
oh that's mother uh mother cecilia now i
remember so we have all these features
in there to make it easier for people
who might be challenged by some of these
things i love that that's like the
doorway of approachability that you're
opening right there and thank you so
much for thinking of that from the start
in your games so super excited to see
those features as well and when you
decided to
create this game and have it set in the
16th century
i must think you do a lot of research i
know you said you studied german history
yeah but do you work with experts how
did that go that process yeah um i
contacted a number of uh people either
that i knew because i did go to
university um for history or people that
i had read about so christopher de hamel
was a consultant for us for illuminated
manuscripts he's like world renowned for
his expertise in that and he's very
helpful for understanding how a working
artist was operating at this time period
dr edmund kern
focuses
well on a lot of stuff but what we used
him for was his expertise in sort of
austria and the holy roman empire
social structure and legal issues at the
time
and then dr winston black who
specializes in medieval and early modern
medicine so we drew upon all of them to
help give a lot more layers of
authenticity to how we represented the
time period
amazing so i'm gonna expect a lot of
details in there i'm gonna learn a lot i
feel like i'm gonna learn a lot
so even though this is a very different
type of game than the obsidian is known
for creating are there any elements that
you would say that continue the
hallmarks of the obsidian titles yeah i
mean you know we wanted to make
something that was different and more
approachable and sort of narrative
focused uh but we also wanted to give
players some choice about how they
define andreas one of the things that's
nice about saying that andreas went to
university is that you can choose
what he studied or really what he was
interested in so you know you can say i
was a latinist i specialized in grammar
so i he knows latin he knows things
about the roman republic and that can
come in handiness in his investigations
casting is actually built on roman ruins
we're in cologne this is a common thing
in this region um he can also choose to
say he studied the occult because some
people don't realize that in this time
period books on magic were
largely circulated among the clergy who
were in university settings so this
gives you the opportunity to unlock
these aspects of his educational
background or is how he lives his life
for example did you live as a hedonist
where you just indulge every pleasure
or are you a businessman who focuses
specifically on making connections and
making money all of these things open up
choices in conversation and how you can
go through the mystery um but then also
it's very important that you feel like
you can shape the story this is a
personal story and the story of a
community but you need to be able to
influence that um you need to ultimately
decide who you think is actually guilty
of these crimes and that's a very
ambiguous thing um we leave that open to
you and it's up to you to sort of see
the consequences of it so it's more than
just a mystery in in general it's like
really an open environment right yeah
exactly um you know the reason why we
don't call this like a detective game
even though there are elements to it is
um it's a narrative adventure
but you are investigating a murder but
we want you to feel like um there is
ambiguity here you're not a detective
there is no forensic science so you are
investigating a number of people who
have motives and it's up to you to
really present the evidence that you
feel is
maybe the most compelling but you don't
have to you could also just turn in the
person that you don't want to be around
anymore the person you don't like as
much or it could be the person you think
the community will miss the least but
the thing is because you're going to be
returning to this community over many
many years if you get someone punished
for a crime the people who are close to
them are going to remember that and
they're going to hold it against you
maybe other people are glad that you did
that and they'll be totally fine with it
but that's that's part of the appeal i
think of an obsidian game is that the
story is more about
living with consequences rather than a
right or wrong answer i can't wait
because that means also for streamers
when they stream the game it can turn
out into different choices i think
there's a lot to explore yeah so what
was the development like of the process
in reality
yeah so i mean i've always wanted to
make a historical game but this
particular type of game i didn't really
conceive of until about the time that
microsoft acquired obsidian um i thought
that a small narrative game historical
with a small team would be a great fit
for game pass
so i pitched my boss fergus ercart i
said i'm going to make this game with a
small team and then i went to hannah and
i said i have this idea for this game
and i have an idea for an art style it's
kind of blending these two eras because
it's a transitional time but i don't
really know how that worked
so
yeah at that point i was really excited
because this was a unique challenge but
i was coming from my concept artwork
from an illustration background so i
loved the idea of this being like a
living book uh
mixing what i love about animation what
i love about games and what i love about
books all together into this project
where we had to kind of dance this dance
between being true to history and being
representative of art that we were
looking at
from this time period with the arts that
would be eye-catching be easy to
understand and work really well for the
format so yeah i was thrilled at that
point and fully on board with this idea
so it's super obvious this game means a
lot to you it's very personal so what
are you two most excited about for fans
to play pentamete and discover them for
the first time
yeah one of the things that i'm most
excited about is this game has been kind
of difficult to clock for people to
figure out like what the genre is and
what it's all about and i think that's
really interesting like i think that
intrigue is exciting and we have this
potential to bring a bunch of different
types of people to the table people that
either might not think that they already
enjoy history or the idea of a historic
game or people that love history and
maybe don't game at all
i think we have this potential to kind
of
have people learn something new in this
context and maybe expand what they
already know that they like and for me
that's that's something that's really
exciting about this project and games in
particular we're at this point now where
there's so many games so games that can
do something
new and a little bit unexpected or just
kind of confuse people in a good way i
love that how about you yeah i think um
you know this story is a really personal
story for andreas and the people in this
community and we've put a lot of effort
into all these like really funny and
cute and tender moments that uh i found
are even in this format which is is um
you know very unconventional art style
and it's all presented through text has
been really emotionally impactful for a
lot of people that have played it and so
i'm really excited to see how how it
resonates with people because um i just
think it's a very cool story and it's
also it feels like a very personal story
not only for andreas but also the
choices that the player makes there's a
lot of really cool reactivity that i'm
excited for people to see
well people can actually see it here at
gamescom for the very first time and
we're already a couple days in today is
the first consumer day what are the
reaction of the fans
um it's been really great i mean i think
that when we announced the game like
hannah said some people were kind of
like
ah this looks cool i don't really know
what it is i'll check it out later and
so we had but some people were really
thrilled just by the subject matter and
the art so we had a lot of people coming
in and playing it who were immediately
like yeah i love this but the other
thing that i thought was cool is even
though this is a niche game
um seeing people come in who admitted
they're kind of skeptical or just kind
of like i don't know what this is yeah
they played through the whole demo and
they walked down they're like i'm hooked
i want to find out more about the story
i love it i love the presentation and uh
yeah it's really exciting just seeing
people play it and have a really
positive response
so last but not least when can we get
our hands on this game we're going to be
able to play it on november 15th of this
year
so once my broadcast is almost finished
i'm gonna go and play pentamen right
after that i'm super excited to play
thank you both so much for being here i
really appreciate it thank you for
having us we really appreciate it yeah
it's been a pleasure
so before we hear from the folks from
the newly announced under the wave let's
look at a totally tubular new collab
featuring your favorite dodge brawlers
and the heroes in the half shell
dodgeball
and turtles that's the level of like 90s
cool childhood me could only ever dream
about grab a slice of pizza sit back
feast your eyes on this upcoming
crossover event in this shiny new
trailer cowabunga dudes
[Music]
people of knockout city you've been lied
to
we've been forced to live beneath your
feet
it is time you saw the truth
we will live in the shadows no more
go
it's time for us to step into the light
the mutant mutiny begins now
hey that's me
watch your language
we can't do this alone
this is a call to all mutants everywhere
we need your help
[Music]
uh
we're here for truth we're here for
justice
we leave so many things behind us
objects
memories
mistakes
[Music]
they sink in time
touch the bottom and go to sleep
silence is full of ghosts
[Music]
and here
voices can only come from the deep
deep
under the waves
[Music]
hey welcome back everyone and whoa i
feel like i need a minute to gather
myself after the trailer that is
beautiful and emotional stuff and i'm so
excited to be sitting here with ronald
quiveck who is one of the lead
developers for under the waves brought
to us by the minds behind echo and dark
days this is one i am super excited
about and before any questions run on
let me just say a massive
congratulations on the reveal must feel
amazing for you and the team to finally
have under the waves out there
hi graeme thanks a lot for your
feedbacks we were really really happy to
announce yesterday the trailer of under
the waves as we work a lot a lot on this
trailer so yeah all the team is really
happy today and we have also a lot of
really good feedbacks for so far so yeah
everyone is happy good it was a real
standout moment that trailer and opening
night live just really shone in that
show and after seeing the trailer i've
got a ton of questions i want to dive
into now let's start on the surface okay
you know give us the overall pitch for
under the weight yeah sure sir uh
firstly
um under the wave is a single player now
which is driven and adventure game it
takes place uh mainly underwater in the
north bay area
and in the late 70s uh settings
uh you play a stan a proficient diver
worked on an old company yeah excellent
right so i'm in but let's dive a little
deeper
my immediate reaction to the trailer
there is that there's a real kind of
emotional part to the story here can you
tell us more about that yeah sure um so
stan has keep some grief from just your
face so
firstly he decided to walk underwater to
to
find some rest from the surface to think
about his own life so so as a game has a
lot of mature topics we really work on
the
atmosphere atmospheric side of the game
on the emotional side of the game so
yeah the main ideas was to create a very
emotional game yeah
yeah yeah you really get a sense of that
kind of escape and that isolation for
stan when he's under the waves it looks
amazing but i also saw some pretty
surreal imagery in that trailer as well
like things you wouldn't necessarily
expect to see under the waves tell us
more about that and how it will play
into the story yeah sure so stan
a lot of grief from the surface and also
a lot of memories to
to to
and to
hide from the surface and um
you know as a diver you sometimes have
some disease like narcos and one day on
the routine mission stan will be
confronted with
the first strange event so at this
moment this will be already the
beginning of a journey of stan
underwater and
as stan will move on those kind of
memories coming back from his past
all the game will fall into some sci-fi
things and yeah a lot of serious things
looks fascinating now i've got to tell
you run on this has really resonated
with me because you know i grew up in
aberdeen scotland right on the north sea
that north sea setting is really talking
to me my dad worked in oil in drilling
what was it that drew you personally to
that north sea setting yeah it's funny
because uh my father was a seller so i i
live uh mainly around the sea also and
yeah for me it was a really good great
inspiration for me to talk about because
uh yeah i see a lot of things for
example about solution into the ocean so
we decided to set up the game in the
north sea because
all the north is quite polluted you have
a lot of oil company you have a lot of
pollution from the second one so far
obviously we really would like to create
strong messages about ecological things
extra we decided to set up the game here
and confront stan to that kind of things
yeah awesome and it's kind of a world we
never see right under the under the
waves literally i guess it gives you so
much freedom to create an environment
for players to explore so how much will
players be able to kind of in an open
world style explore so firstly the game
is really story dragon so you have a man
story to follow but we already designed
the game with very large area to explore
so basically you live in a underwater
but you are able ready to swim in the
under the sea you will be able to
uh drive a little submarine uh and in a
very large area so you can really move
at your covenants in the world uh but
yeah you have a main story to follow and
uh in the ocean you will be able to to
find rakes to find caves we really
wanted to to let the player be free in
the ocean to really create some also
empathy with the ocean and with the sea
life and for us it's really important to
create this connection uh also to fit
our ecological message yeah i love it
something else i loved was the this sort
of 70s retro futuristic vibe you've got
going on with the technology and the
underwater technology
why did you kind of choose that art
style and how are you bringing it to
life sorry it's also come from my
childhood
so uh when i was shy i visited a lot of
boats with my father and all the boats
were in this kind of setup and also i
was a lot a big fan of jackie's
sea documentaries and as also the
stories about reading nostalgia memories
and some stuff like that we decided to
uh be really inspired by those kind of
old sea documentaries so we
treat this kind of rendering we add
grain on the under pelic and the picture
were vinniting
we had some strong contrast between
yellow and blue so we really yeah we
really would like to feed this kind of
old memories all the vintage thing to be
yeah in a comfortable world and uh for
us it's a kind of mud lender proof
madeleine of course yeah cool the music
in the trailer is incredible too like
and such a great way of bringing the
atmosphere of the game to life who's
working on the music for you and how are
you using it to kind of raise those
emotional states yeah so the music was
composed by nicola brodan who is also a
co-founder of the studio so in general
in all of your game we work closely with
a composer with a writer so the idea was
ready to work on the emotional music to
to follow the stand stand stories to the
game so we work with old
synthetism
we work a lot on song design too and the
ideas was ready to be minimalistic and
emotional in the music and with also uh
vibes from 70s so with all the
yeah old scenes etc and yeah our main
reference where uh cigars are write red
very nostalgic music too yeah cool i i
really get a sense that there's a lot of
like personal connection to this game
with you but tell me more about the rest
of the team like how is the process of
creating under the waves yeah i'm sure
we are quite an indie team where a dozen
of uh people are very talented people
for
for for
all the team and uh yeah we come from a
triple a uh company uh so with nicola
brodan the competitor and sebastian
renault the writer
we have created parallel studio to
really craft strong narrative game
because we
we have a lot of
id we we had a lot of stuff memories
some on our own past
so yeah we decided to really create a
game with
many things from us uh
it's a really personal project from all
the team and uh yeah yeah we really
would like to have this kind of uh thing
is the game right now you've also
mentioned there's kind of an ecological
message at the heart of under the waves
as well clearly in the setting with
drilling and industry
um so how are you bringing that to life
and how are you adding that into the
world of the game yeah sure sir
mainly the idea was to
focus
the story and uh about human impacts on
the ocean not to to be uh just
ecological but to create a strong also
strong poetic message about life the
secret of life
because to
to to move into the life we have to be
um
we have to be confronted to seek out of
life itself and when we take some breath
from the life you we we see nature we
see
the life around us so the idea was to
create a poetic message uh around the
story about the sea life about the
the poetic sea life around you and
that's why we really decided to work on
ecological strong message in the game so
for example you will be able to
to find some
strong facts about plastic in the world
and
of course stan will react about um
we have a lot of questions about about
his own impact as a worker of uh you
know our company
and uh to to
[Music]
enhance his
messages we decided to find a foundation
an association
non-governmental and cessation so we
work now with surfrider foundation to
really bring their messages also in the
game and to fix this message
very closely and so you will be able to
find a lot of things about yeah surf
rider in the game yeah awesome and the
work that surf rider foundation is doing
is so inspiring and i know you've got a
video to better introduce us to them so
uh let's take a look
clean water
inspired communities
this is what we fight for
[Music]
on the
ground in the classroom
at the heart of the political debate
every day we take action to battle
plastic pollution
protect water quality
and reduce climate change
powered by a dedicated grassroots
community around europe we are driving
change at every level
to ensure that our ocean and beaches
exist for future generations to enjoy
we protect what we love
since 1990
we are surfrider europe
[Music]
hello everyone i'm remy from safrida
foundation europe all of us at surfrider
are very excited to announce that we are
collaborating with parallel studio and
contigrim to amplify our actions of
protecting the ocean and its users by
bringing our messages to their upcoming
game under the waves as gamers ourselves
we really enjoy seeing how video games
can carry meaningful messages it's
crucial for us to raise awareness of the
richness of the ocean and its
vulnerability we are very pleased to do
that in a whole new way thanks to
parallel studio and country dream
another way's message is about the
beauty of the ocean and the necessity to
protect it we strongly believe in it as
a freedom and we look forward to telling
you more about this collaboration soon
so stay tuned to software.eu for more
information on our mission
and under the wavegame.com for more
information on the collaboration
incredible stuff there and such an
important organization to support so
ronald tell us how surf rider is working
really closely with you on the actual
development yeah sure we we we've done a
lot of brainstorming so we basically we
take a lot of facts from starfighter for
example a quantity of plastic in the
ocean etc so we decided to really add
those messages and facts in the world so
the player will be able to to scan the
area and find some information we'll be
able to find a
more
more complicated more precise uh in fact
through your logbook and we have also
done a really strong work on the
backstory of the game so one of the main
characters is directly linked to the
surfrider and uh so yeah
we really decided to work closely with
them not to just have a
an ecological research but ready to fix
the narrative side the poetic side and
the yeah the real experience side is
about yeah ecologic and the beauty of
the ocean right and i think you've even
got some xbox achievements and you fired
my shirt right all right we have added a
lot of achievements uh for example
collecting a lot of plastic so we think
we think video games could be a really
strong medium for that kind of messages
and for us it's really important to move
with that id yeah totally agree ronald
okay when can we play under the waves
under the wave is for next year in 2023
excellent ronan thank you so much
amazing game looks incredible and a
really important message as well thank
you for your time for joining us here at
gamescom thank you cheers
okay
up next we're hearing about a new era of
xbox
is standing gameplay with harrison
hoffman from the xbox cloud gaming team
throughout the show we have been
highlighting great games that you can
get your hands on later this year into
the next but for this segment we're
going to change it up a little bit and
welcome harrison hoffman who will walk
you through the future of xbox gaming
without having to have an xbox console
now i know i just said what i just said
but could you explain to us what that
really mean yeah for sure so what we're
showing here today is the brand new xbox
app for samsung smart tvs so this is an
app that comes pre-installed on all 2022
samsung smart tvs and all you have to do
is launch the app sign in with your
microsoft account uh pair a bluetooth
controller we actually support
both xbox as well as playstation uh dual
sense and dualshock 4 controllers
and you can just jump right into the to
the game to play well we're right here
right now could you walk us through a
little bit what that app look like yeah
for sure so
right here uh we're on the home screen
of the app so the first thing you'll
notice when when you come in here is uh
we've filled the top of the screen with
your recently played games so we know
from our experience with with the
console that the most common thing that
people do when they come back to play is
just jump right back into something that
they were playing before so we made that
really really easy now if you want to
find something new to play you can just
kind of scroll down from here so you may
have heard recently we made fortnite
free to play on xbox cloud gaming so
again all you need is that microsoft
account you can just jump right in and
play fortnite um but if you have an xbox
game pass ultimate subscription that's
when you unlock you know hundreds of you
know high quality games that you can
just play right here um inside the app
so you can see some of the the game
selections that we that we've curated
for folks here some of our most popular
games forza horizon 5 halo infinite sea
of thieves all the ones that you'd
expect and then obviously our recently
added game so we're constantly adding
new games to game pass and you know i
just kind of come in here like you know
a couple times a week and see what's new
and just and just jump right into it so
you know two point campus turbo golf
racing cooking simulator all ones that
have come out really recently here can
we jump into a game right now yeah let's
do it so let's check out grounded so i'm
super excited for the 1.0 release of
grounded this that's that's coming up
here and i've been checking it out a bit
lately so
let's just load up into the game here so
what's happening right now is we are
connecting you to the best xbox cloud
gaming server for your session here um
and when you're playing in xbox cloud
gaming like you are playing in the xbox
ecosystem so that means that all of your
cloud game saves from your pc or your
console or your phone are all
automatically saved to the cloud so you
can pick up right where where you left
off from anywhere here
um so you can see we're we're getting
into this game and we'll just go ahead
and get the game started and uh what's
happening right here is this game is
running um on our hardware in the cloud
and being streamed down to the tv in
real time at 1080p 60 frames per second
can i try it yeah for sure so let's just
load just load this game up here and
then uh we'll let you
have a shot at it so
uh all right so here we are
at the beginning of grounded and you can
see
i'm running around and one of the most
important things uh when we were
developing this app is making sure that
the gameplay feel is right like the the
latency between uh when you do something
on your controller and what happens on
tv has to be super low and you have to
feel like you're really in control of
the game so you can even see as i'm like
coming around here like how how
responsive this is like you can see i'm
just you know jumping here and it's just
being instantly reflected on the screen
um so let me actually uh let you take a
shot at this can i take the playstation
controller yeah you can take the
playstation controller so
let me let me swap controller for
microphone here
and wow this this is the first time for
me playing an xbox game with a
playstation controller but i know what
you mean like the input feels it feels
great i feel see no latency um i mean it
depends on the internet that you have at
home but this is a big step for gaming
without having to have additional
hardware yeah for sure i mean obviously
uh here at xbox we have been making
consoles for for 20 plus years like i
actually personally worked on you know
series x from early planning all the way
through launch so like myself and a team
have tremendous respect for the gaming
experience that that colleges bring to
tvs but we also know that not everybody
is going to buy a dedicated gaming
device like a console to play so you
know all you have to do like if you have
a tv that that this app works on you
just have to launch the app and you can
play so this is a multiplayer right now
like how can i team up with my friends
here yeah so uh obviously multiplayer a
huge part of the xbox experience so
that's why uh whenever you're in a game
you can hit the xbox button here
i'll just grab my controller back i can
i can take this for you now we're
handling this fine we're great okay
exactly so uh you can come into the
guide here to see um all of your friends
you can see what they're doing uh you
can invite any of them into your game if
one of them invites you to a game you
can come in here to uh view your view
your invitations as well just join right
up um
um achievements a huge part of playing
on xbox you got to be able to unlock
those achievements and and get your
gamer score so you can do that here all
the achievements that you unlock on on
your tv
are reflected across the xbox ecosystem
so i can come in here and just really
see what i need to work on thank you
cloud i would say yeah oh yeah for sure
uh all right how about we how do we
check out a different game
which one are you trying uh well i've
been really into this this new game
called turbo golf racing lately and this
game is brand new on game pass it's
actually in in game preview uh so let's
just hop right in and hover into this
and this is one of those games that you
know when i saw it come up on the
recently like added list you know i
don't have to download it i don't have
to update this game you know so it's
just super simple for me to just go and
try it out and uh it turns out that i
really like it and it's and it's super
fun so so are you go for yourself then
uh
i used to be more of a golfer than i am
now but i do still enjoy it from time to
time
and this is different well i can drive
but i don't golf so i got 50 chance that
i'm good in this game okay okay
all right let's just get right into
a game here so
just pick a solo map here
and we'll see what we can do
so how um often would you switch a game
in one session for example
um i mean it kind of really depends on
the mood that i mean like sometimes i
want to go and just try out a bunch of
different games sometimes you know i'm
super invested in a game that i've been
playing for hundreds of hours and that's
just kind of what i'm what i'm into and
that's just the sort of flexibility that
you get with with cloud gaming here just
being able to to jump into any of these
games uh without any hassle and you know
obviously over the years people have
gotten oh i bounced it off the tree
there uh obviously over the years people
have gotten super used to you know
streaming their movies and tv shows from
apps on their tv like netflix and disney
plus so like we really just want to make
it as easy to stream an xbox game to
your tv as it is to stream like a show
from netflix so well it looked like
you're already pro here and you have
been dedicated some sessions to it yeah
uh struggling a little bit right now but
i swear i'm better when i'm not on
camera
okay so i do have uh one more treat for
you here so
follow me this way i will follow we will
go to the next station i'm thankful
we're having two stations right here
okay let's do it what are we having here
flight simulator okay so uh what we have
here microsoft flight simulator so
obviously this game uh has a huge
history on the pc and you kind of always
need to have like you know a high-end
gaming pc to really be able to enjoy
this um well recently you know we we
brought this game over to series x as
well and it's now playable on on the
cloud so there's no big downloads here i
don't have to have expensive hardware i
can just come in here and fly and
explore so i'm just kind of coming into
beautiful
naples italy right here um
do you want you want to give it a shot
yes of course i never say no to gaming
yeah
thank you so much so fox at home if you
never tried flight sim just really
really i would recommend take a volley
copter take a hello pelican and hover
over the cities because these details
are so beautiful i have to say sobo did
a really amazing job yeah i mean this
this game is beautiful it's just such a
technical achievement too and you know
um all of these textures are just
streaming down from from from the cloud
in real time uh from our azure data
centers and that's really what makes
this whole game possible here
and when is this coming out this is it
right now right yeah it's actually
already out so uh if you have a 2022
samsung smart tv this comes
pre-installed if you just go
into the gaming hub on on your tv then
uh you'll be good to go
thank you so much harrison for walking
us through this and i have to say we've
really come a long way from blowing in
cartridges wiping off our cds to get
into gaming but one thing never changed
and that's the importance of community
and i love to see how platform is
evolving lower down barriers and brings
everybody together and there's one
franchise that brings the community
together like no other and that is
minecraft i'm handing it off to my
co-host frame who's gonna talk about the
upcoming minecraft legends
[Music]
what is my favorite legend of the
overworld
the one i like most tells of a peaceful
land that did not know
cruelty
until it was attacked by invaders
spreading the scourge of greed and fire
it turns of a world on the brink of
disaster
rising to answer the call
my hero
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it tells of struggles
and sacrifices
[Music]
but most importantly this legend reminds
us that hope
can win the day
[Music]
and that when fiery foes seem never
ending
that
is when the world needs legends
the most
[Music]
watch out everyone the piglens are
coming and we're going to talk a lot
about those we guys but before we do i
should introduce not piglins but a
couple of the team members responsible
for the highly anticipated minecraft
legends welcome to the game's executive
producer dennis reese welcome dennis
thank you and creative director magnus
needforsh welcome magnus thank you very
much for joining us today hey welcome
back to gamescom yeah it's great it
feels good to be back right you know
it's nice to be back here in germany
with sausages and video games that's
excellent
all the good things yeah at once those
are a few of my favorite things yeah
right so you announced minecraft legends
at our xbox showcase back in june right
so give us a reminder of what we should
expect from legends
uh well legends is an action strategy
game based in the minecraft universe
that really encourage you to go out and
explore the world
and use all of these resources that you
gather to help defend the overworld
which is being invaded by these horrible
piglets
and yeah it's just it's it's a lot of
fun i think the players are really going
to enjoy getting out and and playing the
game yeah
it's a new game that we're developing at
mojang
we're doing it together with blackbird
interactive
it is a little bit of a different game
because the easiest way to describe it
is action and strategy so it's a kind of
a unique combination of gameplay nice so
it's not the same minecraft that we're
used to but
clearly still set in the minecraft
universe still got all the things we
know and love about minecraft but it
must be so exciting to take that
universe in a different direction right
so why did you choose to do that with
minecraft legends well with minecraft
uh we really like to you know at mojang
we really like to create games that we
love to play
and we're really passionate about
strategy games and years ago people are
sitting around talking about how they
could bring a strategy game into the
minecraft universe
and you know the more talk more talk and
it turned into something that we really
wanted to do and it was uh it was you
know it's passion
really that drove us to this legend
great
and it's kind of uh within the minecraft
universe you do kind of have this kind
of blank slate right to create all these
different experiences yeah exactly fun
to play with yeah now that's a that's
one of the great things you know
minecraft is such a treat it's like it's
for everybody in so many ways we do have
you know the original game that we
usually call vanilla we have done
minecraft legend no sorry we're doing
that now we have done minecraft onions
yeah and uh now we want to bring yet
another game to broaden the experiences
that player can experience within the
minecraft universe right so once the
idea or the sort of seed for minecraft
legends developed like how did you build
the team around it who did you bring
together to work on the game well we we
knew that when we started to go out and
build this there were a couple problems
we had to solve number one
mojing isn't a strategy game developer
it's not something we do and number two
as magnus mentioned you know a real
minecrafter original minecraft is called
vanilla to us and for us
vanilla is really important and the
studio focuses
mostly on vanilla
so we had to go find a partner one who
knew how to build strategy games and uh
and you know one who really had a
passion for minecraft and so we started
looking around and and we uncovered
blackberry interactive okay um they were
known for making the strategy game well
called deserts of carrack and they were
pretty newly formed uh company at the
time but their experience ran deep with
strategy games and the more we looked at
them the more we realized how passionate
they were also
about the minecraft universe we really
thought they could be a great partner
for us and so that's when when we
started moving forward
right and
when we started to work with them they
also you said they were already
passionate but they were also eager to
learn what yeah what's the secret behind
making a minecraft game so it's been
super interesting to work on them like
their creative team just you know
tossing ideas around and could it be
this no could have been this yeah a
great idea and we are kind of like just
you know throwing ideas back and forth
what's good for minecraft and what's not
good for minecraft right yeah it must be
great to bring new people new ideas into
that kind of minecraft melting pot that
must be a ton of fun right oh so much
fun and actually you know the team
started very small uh just a you know a
few of us kind of getting going and then
once we had a good idea as to how we
wanted to progress it slowly got larger
and larger and then you know new people
with a lot of new experience came on
board and i remember magnus actually
magnus came on with two three years ago
and uh and when he came on
his experience with open world games
completely changed how we wanted to
think about legends and we we were able
to take a lot of his experience and
apply it to legends to really create a
better experience and i mean and that's
the story across the board with lots of
the folks from uh from you know the team
as it grew and it's i really enjoy it
it's been it's been a great experience
oh magnus yeah work
well thank you
now it's it's a pleasure to work with
them and you know the whole team is
fantastic to work and as danny said i
can came aboard a couple of years ago
but i also saw the energy that already
existed there like everybody was so
excited and it was a great to you know
for me to learn a new environment in a
new type of games like come a little bit
from a different background yes i made
open world games i can bring that
experience but minecraft is so different
so it was a lot a lot of
super fun learning for me as well coming
to mojang you know really get of course
i played it almost since day one because
you know back in the day they were
mojang was a studio across the street
from me so like we we've known it i
known it for a long time but just you
know getting to know it for real working
with all the creative people those at
mojang but as well as blackbird you know
just
that's that's what i like to do as you
know my in my creative leadership i kind
of like to do
leader teams you know just get them
together but there's so much
creativity going on
and
you know get that
snowball effect of just talking about
ideas and so on it's so fun i think he
even listens to me
the executive producer every once in a
while every now and then every now and
then
that's amazing now speaking of the team
now one of the things that fascinates me
about this is that blackbird are in
canada right yeah magnus you're in
sweden yes dennis you're in redmond near
seattle right so you've got three
completely different geographical
locations how do you pull all that
together uh well it's you know a lot of
work and dedication from the team in
general um but that's the thing we've
we've managed to uh change our hours
when we need to
uh and you know also bbi has been very
accommodating when we all need to travel
to a location and be on on site work
together we just make it work
but really it comes down to that passion
and working together it's like it's fun
we really enjoy each other's company um
and you know what start us as just sort
of work relationships really has become
more friendship and so you're willing to
endure some of that time zone change so
that you can you know enjoy spending
time i stare at magnus on the screen so
much
yeah you're crazy you kind of like i
don't know when you go up with often for
i normally go to bed so i don't know but
yeah but you're up pretty late too so
we just make it work yeah exactly but
yeah no like
making games is always a bit of
challenge like it's
it's not easy to make these kind of
games but it i i think it's it's an all
that struggle that you as dennis said
you make friends in in real life and so
on and just get along together and have
a good time
you know
struggles makes people come together in
a good way yeah absolutely so you talked
about minecraft legends as an action
strategy game right why did you choose
that genre and um you know tell us what
that means from a gameplay sense
well
so what we we wanted to make sure that
uh when we choose it any games within
the minecraft universe
that uh you know they're unique and
different and really you can look at
legends for example we we did that where
we uh we wanted to bring a dungeon
crawler experience into the minecraft
universe and so in doing so we wanted to
make it feel very minecraft and and
that's that's what we did with the
strategy game here with with legends is
we really wanted to make sure that we
are authentic to what minecraft was as
we bring it into you know a strategy
experience into the universe and you
know i mean that's
what danny said
in the beginning
it was an idea that hey we should have a
strategy game within the minecraft
universe
and that would be cool but another
aspect of minecraft is that we all
always have a hero character so the hero
character is there and that's not common
in strategy games you usually
control a strategy game by a mouse
pointer or something like that right so
bringing that hero like letting the
player feel like they're part of the
game world is super important in all our
games
so
that kind of founded hey how can we
combine these two types of game where
you're one part hero centric with one
part controlling armies and so on it's
that's really been really interesting
and when we kind of started to realize
that
it's hey this is quite new and as a game
maker when you find something you feel
this isn't
like there's not 10 games like that out
there then you feel like you're
something on to something special so
actually it was
the thing that brought me really into
this project was kind of my first day
two of the team members just sat down
directly described the game to me and i
kind of like all in
almost in that day felt like wow we have
something great here because i haven't
heard anything like this before and so
and then we just kept rolling with that
action strategy idea okay
this might sound like a silly question
but right action strategy where do you
find the balance right because action is
quite immediate it's quite visceral
strategy is a little bit more
step back assess the situation so
where's the balance in legends
it's uh it's hard to balance games
always but
i would say
it's hard to draw a pie chart of you
spend 73 percent in strategy mode and
this percentage in another mode and so
on but
it's
it's like
i'm surprised how well it actually fits
together now like the because they go
into each other and they complement each
other in really good way
one thing that we wanted to do from the
beginning is to make a strategy game
that works well on console right
that's hard with the traditional like
but it's actually
strange to think about it but the pace
of a strategy game is often higher than
an action game because you're so quick
of scrolling around
maneuvering around with your cursor and
so on quickly click and you do
very very many actions in a very very
short time in a strategy game normally
so having a hero at the center that
can't be there there there there
actually surprisingly enough brings down
the tempo of a strategy game which is
very well suited to make it play well on
consoles by a controller so like just
adding those two types it was kind of a
surprise i wish i could be smart and sit
there and say yeah we thought about that
from the beginning but sometimes you
need to be honest and say this that's
something that we discovered as we
prototyped and developed again what
happened
yeah exactly
that's one of the things i find really
interesting about this is you know you
made the point you're not controlling a
cursor you're actually controlling a
character you have to deliberately
traverse the environment and you know
physically move within the game right so
how do you handle that within the game
design like actually getting around the
world
uh well it was actually really great
because it's easy to navigate as you go
about and and run through the world you
are on a horse uh within minecraft uh
you know that's possible in vanilla but
um but here you're always on your horse
right so you're able to navigate all
types of terrain quickly get to where
you need to execute your commands and
then
also there's other areas in the game
that you as you're running through the
world you'll uncover new elements like
for example we have speed wheat which
gives you an instant speed rush
or actually mushrooms within the world
which allows you to jump extra high and
then you can use those abilities to
access other areas of the world in uh
you know quick or uh you know strategic
ways
oh and let's given that you've gone in a
slightly different direction here a
different genre
you know what inspirations did you pull
from within you know other things you've
done within minecraft as well but then
maybe some external influence as well
other games yeah well
for me like i really look
not to external games to to make this
reference but more internal like
you know
dungeons minecraft dungeons
taught so much to the art organization
on to how to bring
a new game that is not your traditional
minecraft experience a dungeon crawler
to the players and
like i i personally think we learned so
much just from that game alone that
we're applying to legends to make sure
that we can bring another game in the
right way i would definitely say that's
a great reference
yeah
well inspiration on the creative side
obviously as you mentioned
minecraft in general like we
all our games we want to stay true to
you know creative people are so fluffy
and it's hard to tell but that minecraft
feel
it's like hard to describe in other ways
otherwise but you know it immediately
exactly we know it immediately but
other than that it's i don't want to
play point out this special game because
as we have been talking it's kind of a
unique combination it's not like any
other game out there that's rare it's
but
of course there was a few games like
this in the 90s in the early 2000s not
very many but technology now makes it
too
possible to push that even further we're
having more troops and so on
so
i can't say there's a one game or
several games but you know just play a
lot of games and enjoy them and you will
draw inspiration for so many things
one thing as a creative i think it's
unusual to hear that people but it's i
like to think about you should throw
inspiration from things that you don't
think is that good either
so when you play games that you feel
like
i'm missing something here what can i do
to make this a better game as well so
it's kind of strange to be inspired by
bad things but that's actually true for
myself yeah that's a super constructive
way to be inspired right it's building
on something that's awesome so when you
think about the player you're aiming for
is it more of a sort of classic
minecraft player or is it more of a
classic strategy fan uh yes yes it's all
over the above yeah you know that's
that's one thing is that we really
wanted to create an experience that if
you're not a strategy game player that
you can enjoy right and if you are a
strategy game player then you know we'll
we'll give you a great experience that
you can enjoy as well and i think that
we're really nailing it like we're
actually it's it's coming along uh i was
not a traditional hardcore strategy game
player but i found myself really really
enjoying
what we're creating to the point where
i've started experimenting so i'm
playing some other games now and it's
kind of broadened my
my exposure to the genre and so i have a
feeling there's going to be a lot of
other players you know similar to me
right yeah
it is has been important to obviously to
get a as a broad target audience as
possible but i think again with
minecraft
it's possible because we are already
reaching out so reaching so many players
and so on so obviously
all the players who knows minecraft now
get a new way of enjoying minecraft but
at the same time it's super important to
remember that
even though a lot of players play
minecraft or have played it in the back
like past and so on
this game is also totally possible you
don't need to have played minecraft you
don't need to know what minecraft is to
enjoy this game you can come on come on
in and this game will help you to
understand what the minecraft universe
is and bring you into the wonderful you
know thing we have going on there
excellent i want to talk more about the
hero we touched on the hero earlier yeah
i just find it really fascinating like
how did you center the experience and
this idea of action strategy around that
hero character
uh you know the hero coming into the
world and that element of uh exploring i
mean that it's it's very minecrafty
right so applying it here was just
something that we wanted to make sure we
did
uh and i don't know magnus you could
probably touch on a little better
exactly
i should say the hero is important but
it's it's kind of like because it's
important in all our games like that's
the center we want that to be a
a you know a
extension of a player almost right so
the the kind like
the there is a story told about hero
coming into that led this legend and so
on but the game structure is relatively
open so you can play it however you want
uh in the order you want to and so on
we'll push on the stereo the story
depending on what actions you take with
your hero
so you move through the story in the
campaign
but at the same time as we want that to
be the core of the game it's not in
gameplay everything it's so much more
about that you are a character coming to
this world
and you know uniting everybody who is
here
against the threat
that the piglets are so you need to come
here to make a lot of friends
and they will together with you help you
to defeat the piglets so
it's it's not about getting stronger or
you're not getting a new arm or anything
like yeah it's more or less make friends
you know play around with them have a
good time and defeat the piglets
together
it's a great message though isn't it
it's like it's almost like you're
building connections you're building
alliances you're uniting yeah exactly
against a common enemy i didn't think
about this but i said before like it's
kind of like game dev i said like
struggles makes you come together and
you're able to overcome obstacles and
that's kind of what you do in the game
as well as the hero yeah there is a
struggle the picklings are attacking we
need to defend so everybody comes
together and then we defeat the piglets
and i love that and it's with your team
as well yeah you know you're bringing
this team together from lots of
different places yeah very very very
cool all right it's time to talk piglets
ah yes we want to talk piglets i mean
what's their deal and why did you choose
them as the bad guys what's up with them
okay what's up with the piglets uh you
know
piglets exist in vanilla yeah um and
they yeah they were great for us to
bring them out into legends and expand
on them and so you know there's there's
sort of different versions of what
piglens exist in legends uh compared to
what they are in vanilla but they're you
know these
horrible mean kind of ugly cute
characters that look like they really
stink
but
it's just they sort of invade and
they're just causing nothing but
problems and you know here they are in
the overworld destroying it and that's
where you the hero comes to play to try
to you know unite that overworld and
take them back and yeah that's uh
definitely a big piece yeah they as you
said they are ugly cute right
they're so charming and we felt that
from the beginning like of all the mobs
that we have we like all our mobs in the
minecraft universe but the pickling had
such a potential to be kind of like the
bad guys right in the game where you it
was easy to see wow we can make this
version of a piglet with that marlin so
we have expanded the
the range of picklings in in many
different way as you saw the trailer
when we started up you many new types of
pickings within the game and so on so
it's it's pretty cool so tell me about
some of those different types of
picklings i want to know what we're
coming up against well we actually
there's one of them we just uh just
debuted here in the trailer that you
just saw
is called the picmodillo and uh yeah
it's the one that comes out of the
portal and then kind of hunches up into
like a cube and rolls at you
very difficult to defeat and uh one of
the more fun ones yeah yeah another one
is the bruiser it's uh it's another one
you've seen in the trailer
it comes out and has like two kind of
razor blades on its arms and does you
know some really wicked moves as it as
it comes and attacks you uh but yeah
that's that's a very fun one too
there's lots of different types of
piglets yeah we have expanded in so many
ways so that's a couple of
like detailed units another thing that
we have done is you can like build up
at
almost like a society like we have
different boards as we say here's game
comes we have been presenting a port of
the bastion
and so the different hordes
differentiate both in look but primarily
in the game how they play how you play
against them and so on so they you need
to like
think about how you engage in combat
with the different words in different
ways
so
they look and feel different and it's
just fun to engage with them right so
what kind of units do you as the hero
player then bring to bear against the
piglets
well i mean for example uh you know
magnus referenced how the the
horde of the bastion has wireless
structures so one of the stu or one of
the units you're going to want to use on
your side is one called the cobblestone
golem that's very good against
structures so you can take the
cobblestone golems and attack and get a
lot a lot more uh results a lot better
results another one is the plank golem
uh you saw a horrible demise of a plane
column uh in the trailer actually but
that's one of the ranged units and uh
that's very very good as you attack to
use those in tandem
uh i don't know any others you can think
of well i'm thinking more about the way
that you need to engage with them
because they as i said the ports are
playing differently the horde of
sebastian for example
it's almost here without the name right
they like to build forts they entrench
themselves and so on so you needed like
grind your way into their bases and to
defeat the portals at the center of it
while others are more open and so on so
how you think about your unit
composition which friends you bring with
you in each fight and so on and also the
way you lead them like you can
you can lead your friends
into battle in so many different ways
yeah
i love exploring the bases yeah like
take a hike get to the high ground look
at the base and evaluate what is the
best way i want to attack this space
yeah and then use the tools your units
as you see fit to go and do the best
results possible yeah it's it's good
variation right
so a lot of gameplay variation a lot of
different units we will show more as we
go along yeah up until the launch of the
game so that's great you know as you're
talking through there
it feels like yes you're taking the
genre in a new direction but it's also
giving you a new direction to talk about
the lore of minecraft world and the mobs
that we already know and maybe love and
finding out more about them is that is
that right
yeah absolutely it's uh
like part of that minecraft feel like
talking about you can call that for lore
but we want to have a a little bit of a
mystery going on around what's you know
what's going on in minecraft and so on
and that's that's how we work with it so
we are kind of like
doing things in the different games
where you can find hints of what's going
on in another game and especially our
community they're so good at kind of
like trying to figure out what we want
them to figure out and so on like so we
bring some secret messages and then try
to decipher them yeah all the time and
it's like i want to be clear when we
announced the game
i mentioned that
or that uh jens had a shirt on
which was a hint as to what badger
became today none of us
are wearing any sort of hints about
future games so just letting you know
i've been very closely examining that
feature
trying to figure out
take a freeze frame of that everyone
yeah
all right amazing magnus dennis thank
you so much for your time it's been
great just to talk about minecraft
legends
when can we see more when can we hear
more
it's uh well you can learn more by
following us our all our you know social
channels twitter so on you can also at
minecraft.net follow up on a newsletter
so you will get that wow that's loud
yeah
i don't know
yeah microphone
all right minecraft live yeah well later
this year we will have minecraft live
great we'll come there and tell quite a
bit more about the game so okay more
secrets to reveal
more stickers
fantastic hey brilliant seeing you both
welcome back to gamescom thanks an
absolute
it's excellent thank you thank you all
right before we close out the show with
learning everything you want to know
about age of empires maxie and i had a
bit of fun walking around the booth
earlier today so let's take a look
it's so exciting to have a physical
foods bag great how do you feel i love
it it's so good to be back we're three
years away but it's amazing we're here
we're back at gamescom and the best
thing is communities all getting back
together again we're playing some games
it's great and we want to show you that
boost so let's start here what do we
have right here well yeah i mean lots of
change in the last three years but sia
thieves is still here season seven just
released so much good news stuff in
there and of course you can play it on
the show floor here at our booth but
there's more as well right there is more
and we're going to check it out right
now let's take a look
hey you can't be a proper pirate without
some pirate ink so welcome to the sea of
thieves tattoo studio here oliver how
you doing tell us what you're doing yeah
i'm doing pretty fine um basically we're
doing amber tattoos so you can choose um
any of the game designs achievements
thingies and have them spray painted
onto your arms heads legs whatever
shirts keep up the good work and maxi i
think you got one done earlier right
finally i can break up it's amazing it
has glitter on it i really recommend
glitter i don't think it's gonna get any
better than this but let's check out the
other stuff okay let's do it
this is really amazing if you wanna have
a memory to take to your home you can do
photos vote opportunities you can do a
short video and this one is a sea of
thieves version absolutely so we better
give it a go right yeah let's do it yeah
three two one
so this is a trigger warning if you have
arachnophobia close your eyes right now
absolutely there's no danger dumplings
here folks say hello to the grounded
brood mother
these guys don't look too scared though
it's totally fine it's so much fun
so grounded 1.0 is gonna come out in
full campaign mode with the first boss
encounter the brute mother on the 27th
of september on xbox game pass right
here that's correct
oh my god it just touched me frame come
on let's get out of here let's go i like
it
now one of the most exciting games on
the booth especially for the german
crowd is pentamen right maxine yeah
especially for me because the region is
set in bavaria bavaria is my home state
i live in munich and it's obsidian
medieval narrative game and you play
andreas mala over 25-year lifespan and
just solve mysteries great but listen
there's even more at play let's take a
look
[Music]
you see so what do you know it's more at
play it is it is i see you suck at
parking light your frontier planet
atlanta inclination amazing it's great
isn't it and in the 18 plus area over
the back we've got a black tale requiem
and we've got benedict fox and then of
course the game that everyone's talking
about lies of p and it's coming day one
to game class right but that's not it we
even got more to play so if you're here
super excited and let's go on with the
stream it's great to be back everyone
we'll see you soon
[Music]
there's more than one way to win a
battle
and every empire must find their own
path to victory
whether you strike from afar or ambush
up close the malians will use which and
strategy to out maneuver their opponents
and gain the advantage on the
battlefield
powerful speech tools and the ability to
rally large formations the ottomans can
keep the pressure on to bring down their
enemies defenses
[Music]
when the drums of war beat how will you
emerge victorious
history is in the making
and your place in it has just begun
i swear i could watch that trailer three
more times at least but alas we are
coming to the end of the show today so
we wanted to make sure we go out with a
proper bang or in our next case an
ancient battle and what better way to do
that than to talk ancient conquest with
burt beekman studio head from forgotten
empires hello and welcome bert
hey charlie good to be back at gamescom
after all these years with age of
empires absolutely yeah and i don't tell
you what before we dive into anything i
do want to ask you how good it feels to
be back with the german fans because i
know how much age really resonates with
them is amazing like there's such a
massive fan base here in germany like
just walking around
all the halls with your age vampire
shirt yeah people are just stopping
you're like wait eight where can i play
where can i find that yeah they actually
they have stories to tell as well like i
played this for years i played as a kid
yeah i'm still playing it it's it's
amazing it's such a such an amazing
franchise and i have got to say we did
do our xbox fan fest last night and i
was over in the corner playing it for 90
minutes instead of talking to anyone and
i don't regret a second it feels at home
when i'm playing age you know it's just
so lovely and warm a perfect good use of
your time yes yeah that's what i think
right okay let's dive into it and start
talking about it from there so um in the
trailer we just saw we saw that there
are two new civilizations on the way
joining age of empires four and they are
the ottomans and the malians so we're
going to talk about both of them but i
want to kick things off with the
ottomans so yes what have you got to
tell us about them uh loads so good
let's let's let's start with the history
because in the end everything in age of
empires is grounded in history right
so we're looking at the ultimate empire
uh what was all happening and that's all
yeah in the middle ages yeah uh and uh
yeah if you think about that it was an
empire that lasted a very long time it
was very based on military very
militaristic very organized a lot of
military science going on very
regimented army uh that really
controlled a massive area in the middle
east for a very very long time okay uh
and then the question was how do we turn
that into a game yeah how do we turn
that into age of empires uh and it was
really like
okay we have all this military piece
yeah that's that sounds like something
we can translate and i actually want to
dive straight into the gameplay um
so for example the ottomans they have
the military school okay yeah
a brand new building that can build it
in the dark age uh straight from the
beginning straight from the beginning
okay i don't know what this building
does yet but that sounds like a game
changer that it's immediate okay
actually a game changer absolutely
absolutely um so you built a military
school and it's automatically trains a
unit that you select like you have all
toggles for all the units in the
ultimate roster wow and you can select
which one you want to create
for free
i feel like there's a butt coming though
right there is a butt coming there is a
butt coming yes the training goes very
very slowly okay but i suppose the
sacrifice of a slow training is three
armies you still get the free army yeah
there's people those folks who want to
go for combat victories if you're not
draining your resources you can just
build this well this massive empire of
meanies to go to see everyone up exactly
yeah so it's and that's also kind of how
the ultimates play out like you jump
into the game as the ottomans and it's
really all about the military and the
military conquest and winning true
very military means that's that's how
you win as the ultimates yes uh what's
also nice about the ultimate is like the
first time i i played it like a pretty
advanced version already
it's like you feel straight at home like
you have played other age of empires
four civilizations and they're all quite
different from each other yeah but you
get the hang of it quite quickly yeah so
it really resembles the rest you feel at
home and there's not a steep learning
curve on it not not too much though
okay so can you tell us any more about
any of the military units or any of the
buildings
so we we have the the military school
right and they can't trade all the units
and they have quite a few unique units
as well
uh first they have the the janissary uh
a bit of a fan favorite like the chinese
there was in age of empires too was an
age of impress three uh it was always
like the way that the ottomans got their
gun powder any er earlier than any other
civilization in the game advantage yeah
oh yes yeah uh and it's the same here at
html by so we're continuing this
tradition yeah they can build a generous
area it's a hand cannoneer that they
create in the castle age so before
anyone else
uh so yeah you can uh yeah rush to your
guns yeah they really do they definitely
have that combat edge right oh yes oh
yes
amazing so what i want to know though is
if i was to go over that booth over
there or when i play it when it comes
out what's the strategy behind them is
it literally just to build an empire
constantly or is there a pace to it how
would you recommend fans approach there
is definitely there's one
completely novel thing that the ottomans
have and it's the imperial council and
that will play a big big part into your
strategies and how you kind of play the
ultimate civilization uh the imperial
council is kind of as you built your
empire no matter how like researching
technologies going to the next age
training units um you kind of gain
experience i say experience points uh
you get viziers
look at your empire and say like this
has my approval
i shall grant my uh services to you yeah
and those viziers can then say okay i'm
going to give you tactical advantages
like hey
i'm gonna
make sure that you can conscript some
janissaries from the town centers and
you can use those to your advantage in
your next uh attack oh okay so it's
really like you have to pick like do i
go for something more military go
something more economical i think more
building up yeah a lot of options there
and i know you guys like to do something
a bit zany so is there anything a bit
different about the ottomans any other
characters we want to talk about there
is definitely one unit that is a bit
different from everything else i hope
you're going to say what i think you are
we we have the master coming up and
apologies for my turkish accent there
but it is a uh it's a cavalry unit yeah
but he doesn't fight uh but he makes
sure that people around him fight so
it's a it's a drummer cavalry
and depending on the the beats he's
drumming yeah uh he kind of has an aura
around him to improve nearby units okay
so if he's doing like metal music or
drum and bass everyone's getting a
different vibe and going forward yeah
yeah exactly like i don't know yeah with
rock music you go faster with metal
music you get a bit angry i'm not sure
so it'd be like an attack buff wouldn't
it if you put like some like slipknot
drums on or something there we go there
we go
very angry jen is next to you but yes
very very good okay wonderful so we're
gonna jump from them now to the mallions
do they have any little drummer boys but
if not what do they have going for they
have a lot
but a lot going for them
i kind of want to start in the history
again so 100 this is
so when we look at the malians the
malian empire actually was a
massive empire in western africa
their famous the most famous malian ever
was mansa musa and the reason he was so
famous is because he was the richest man
to ever have lived in the history of
humanity oh wow well up until like even
now or just until now until now can i
just say this is literally better than
going to school i learned so much about
history playing this game it's absurd
there are stories about him that he went
to uh he liked to travel yeah like he
liked to trade with his straight caravan
through the deserts and visit uh towns
and he was known for going to those
towns
uh spending so much gold because he had
so much gold
he completely crashed the economy of any
village that he passed
so that's one samusa anyways
it's it's a nice background to have
because we're talking about all these
gold yep and the malians are all about
gold
when you build up your empires the
malians you have this special building
called the golden pits
and you can build it on a gold mine
and then automatically extract skulls
from the gold mines automatically yes
you don't need villagers and it also
doesn't subtract gold from the gold mine
so technically it's infinite gold
infinite gold hack it is
yes but it's not a hack it's actually
you've just put it in the game it's not
a bug it's a feature so
uh famous words yes uh that's huge
though especially for some of the late
game builds where gold comes into play
really heavily or if you're in a map
that's absolutely infested with enemies
and you can't get to the next gold mine
that's that's humongous wow there is a
catch however there's always a catch
always there's always a catch but yeah
i'm so sorry uh you all
you can build those golden pits like the
the pit mine story all over the map uh
but you need to be able to protect them
well of course and that's that's quite
difficult i feel like if i was an
ottoman up against a malian i would go
for that verse you would but then the
the the ultimate is trying to rush you
and then what so it's it's like this you
you get the golden the the the pit mine
story yeah all the way out in the map
how are you going to protect it it's
very very hard and this is where the
strategy of the game and this is where
yeah
exactly can you tell me any more about
any buildings or any new units we're
going to see with the mallions the units
it's i i
we don't have time to go through all of
them unfortunately
every single unit for the malians is
different
uh it does they don't have a standard
roster okay i say that they have a
standard archer that's it
yeah everything else is different uh
they for example they have a spearman uh
that is uh actually donzo
is their name uh it's a unique spearman
it's different because he has two spears
now i like them already you like them
already but
there's more to it it's not just like
he's fighting with two spears but he he
takes his first spear throws it yeah so
the first arranged attack and then he
can fight uh the rest of the ball and
there's no animation for him to go pick
it up or anything unfortunately not it
it will be brilliant i'd love to see
that but uh or if you missed any apps oh
god though let me go get it again or if
he misses it like oh come on
that's brilliant okay i like the sound
of that do we have to talk about
buildings though you got to give me
something on buildings i want to give
one more unit and one more building
because they're actually very
interesting uh we have the uh musafadi
musafadi is a uh uh it's kind of a
hunter
uh unit okay and uh her special ability
is that she is uh she can go into
stealth mode oh interesting all right so
it's kind of this metadorm unit that can
go into stealth mode sneak around the
map
everywhere and then just like surprise
attack are we talking like bog of war
stealth or when when they're in forest
units at stealth or so yeah age of
empires indeed has a stealth forest but
this this unit she can go into stealth
anywhere on the map anywhere okay as
soon as she attacks of course she
reveals herself well yes yeah it smells
like ghosts smoking you or anything
they're not fighting ghosts no no
then they reveal themselves yeah uh but
yeah that's that's kind of the story
behind the hunter the hunter woman
actually mussofati like is malian for
power woman so we have uh i love them
yes okay and you say that they're
aligned with a building in game as well
yes indeed so uh they're hunters that's
kind of their background uh and you can
also one of the landmarks that you can
build is the hunter fortress
and every infantry unit that is kind of
around this fortress also goes into
stealth mode
so i don't even know what to say about
that is that something that you found in
your historical textbooks is that people
would disappear around it what was the
logic behind adding that the the story
is kind of like they were hunters if you
want to hunt and you want to yeah hunt
your prey you of course you need to be
sneaky you need to be stealthy
exactly
and that's kind of the story behind that
uh it's very interesting to play with
yeah no i can imagine i'm thinking about
this is me imagining me playing the game
now if you were to go and attack that
base you'd see this stealth fortress and
you would have no idea what was waiting
for you absolutely no idea the limits of
how many people you could hide in that
radius to go there get this yep yep
amazing so um we spoke a little bit well
actually i'd say we spoke quite a lot
about the mallees and ottomans sounds
like there's more to come um but they
are they've been they're new to age of
empires but the list is pretty long of
how many civilizations there are now
right yes we we're now within 10
civilizations yeah so we had uh eight
civilizations that launched last year we
had the the the english the french the
mongols chinese
uh many more in europe and asia and now
we're expanding to africa with somalians
and the middle east with the ottomans
you're probably going to say these dudes
are the new ones but i'm curious do you
have any personal favorites or any
civilizations do you think you've played
the most i
you know i mean
i really really loved play testing the
mullions because there's one more that i
really really loved about playing them
um i i built this whole empire right
without my my trade routes my gold mines
my little mining towns yeah and at the
end of the game okay i won against ai
i'm not bragging but a win is a win
uh i i
i looked at my empire at the end of the
game and i was like this looks good this
actually looks like a big malian empire
and it felt so good that you've built
something yeah you destroyed something
of course yeah but it's like the victory
felt even better yeah
i think aesthetic goes a very long way i
would love for you to start grading us
on the aesthetics i'm very purposeful
when i build about where i put
everything so i'm like oh a normal
village wouldn't have a house here
i've got to do my little housing area
and a little suburb and whatnot so
exactly i'm totally with you on that one
but yeah i totally agree the way that
you could just build and create very
realistic authentic villages is
incredible um i do want to touch a
little bit though on the fact that it
has been 10 months since age of empires
4 came out um how much has the game
evolved since then
uh relic and and all their death
partners have been incredibly busy uh so
uh there have been many updates many
patches uh in in many various ways like
we've had features new features coming
in like we've had uh color pickers for
people we had more remappable hotkeys
we've had loads of balance changes we
had new maps uh
new zoom levels like i
yeah loads the list just goes on and on
and on and i'm gonna take us back in
time now if there's anyone out here who
didn't know the age of empires was first
released in 1997
yes and i'm curious how the developers
keep building on a franchise to keep it
new and fresh when the focus is on
history it's just so incredible it's i
mean there's just so much world history
and and
anything goes in native empires like if
it's if it happens we can probably put
it in the game in some way yeah and if
we're just looking at uh the last
12 months like we've had the release of
age of empires four we've had two
expansions two dlcs for age of empires
two definitive edition and two dlcs for
age of empires three definitive edition
wow so it's and the fact you've got
definitive editions as well
people want so much age
people want so much age everybody
there's more and more age to come so
that's we've got that squared away and
it's
also thinking about like the franchise
has been going around since 1997. yeah
25 year anniversary right exactly yeah
yeah
the fact that like this is
if anything the best time to join age
vampires because there's just so much
going on so even if you're like hey 25
years i've never tried it try it now and
i will say it's a very wholesome game
with a community that's deeply devoted
and beloved the game so much um and i
wanted to ask what it's like to work on
a franchise that it's not only positive
we've seen so many games just on the
show today that everyone loves it's
really positive but you're with someone
that's been positive for 25 years and
people love it what's that like
uh i mean it's amazing like uh just
looking at my own personal instagram
i've been working on the game for 10
years now i i started to play the game
when i was 10 years old
uh if you told 10 year old me that i
would be sitting here today i wouldn't
have believed it i'm going to copy that
you
and that's and that's the beauty about
it like that the community is so large
so vibrant so active yeah yeah uh it's
it's just it's just amazing it really is
yeah yeah it's such a treat um so what
we're gonna do is gonna talk a little
bit now about looking ahead new stuff
like that uh and and how these
civilizations are introduced so you're
dealing with ancient armies and deciding
which ones to add to the game and so i'd
love to know a little bit more about
what the process is on deciding which
ones you're going to go for and how to
keep it historically correct and
authentic because i know that's
something you guys really really care
about yeah yeah so uh let's let's take
the malians as an example also uh first
thing you do is you go to the library
and you go to the section of western
african history you take anything you
can yeah and you all become bookworms
yeah basically you start reading you
start reading you start picking a part
like the facts uh the the military
battles uh interesting things that
happened interesting buildings and
military tactics that they employed he
just put everything together and from
that you start to distill gameplay and
think like oh hey we talked about a
hunter woman yeah we can do something
with that uh-huh we can do something
with that uh and like that you kind of
just evolve it
uh you have your design you put it in
the game uh and at that point you kind
of want to see like hey what do i have
here is this still a bit authentic is it
still a bit real uh and we talk a lot to
uh experts in the field like
we're not going to say that we're
experts in mali and history not at all
or enthusiasts
in history yes
and we love what we're doing but we need
to have a pro voice in there that says
like hey what you're doing is that
actually still a bit accurate are you
still representing malian culture in the
way that what kind of voices answer that
for you is it researchers the historians
diversity we get in touch with
universities we got in touch with uh
experts likes
there are people who specialize in uh
weaponry of western africa yeah well you
can talk about to those people about
these specific weapons uh but more
practically like for example the
languages that we have in the game uh if
you play as the malians uh you start in
the dark age uh they
speak their ancient malian language but
as you advance through the ages they
speak more and more modern languages
that's a dedication to authenticity that
i truly respect it is amazing it feels
good to just like feel your empire
evolve as you're playing yes yes but
again i don't speak malian we need to go
with you know someone who does exactly
exactly and that's kind of the balance
we try to find because in the end it's
still a video game right yes it is a
video game it needs to be fun but we
want to make sure that the civilizations
that are in the game are represented in
a way that is respectful absolutely yeah
especially when you give that back to a
community the community and i'd love to
talk to them a little bit now because
the i've seen how personally committed
they are myself included i'm part of a
group called the court of ages which is
a bunch of women who like to play and
test and it's just the most wholesome
place ever um and i'm curious to know
how the age of empires community have
actually impacted or helped age four
along the way uh looks uh good to know
yes
let's keep it like that
so for the longest time the age of
empires community has been involved with
uh development like hey do you like this
here's the beta here's an alpha version
let's play let's develop let's give
feedback and let's build the game that
we all want to play in the end
and that also continues today like we
have the h
h vampires insiders you can't go to age
office.com sign up as an insider and
just register for future betas uh you
can go to the age of empires forums like
all the developers are there
we we talk there a lot on the forums
and just like yeah we have pro console
we have other councils we have so many
groups of players that just provide
feedback and yeah we work with everybody
to try and make and uh yeah bring the
best into age of empires amazing and i
feel like i need i need to be the voice
of the community here and i feel like i
have to ask you we know about the
addition of the ottomans and the malians
can you maybe give us a hint about maybe
any upcoming ancient civilizations that
might be added i've got to try but yeah
that's right yeah cheeky
so uh first of all age of empires is of
course more than civilizations we have
more maps coming more features yeah yeah
that's that is coming later as well with
this new civilization
uh i can't say more than that but all i
can say asia vampires is alive
and uh yes alive well and thriving yes
absolutely absolutely so i will do that
and say with it being alive and well are
there any events or updates coming up
that we can look forward to instead
uh yes so uh first of all uh
just to rephrase the 25th of october the
ottomans and the malians will be coming
for free
keyword free free wow okay
to age of empires four so if you have
bought age of empires for in the past on
any platform you will get the news two
civilizations for free and does that
include game pass as well yes that
includes gameplay oh my goodness i love
this conversation everybody gets the new
civilizations yes uh speaking about
things that are for free
right now at this very moment you can
play h154 for free on steam wow okay so
if you were ever on the fence like hey
will i like that game go try it out go
to steam why not go to hvan buy sport
you can try it out
everything is unlocked so you can play
the whole game uh-huh uh till the 29th
of october yeah
october august 29th sorry sorry sorry
yes it happens we're live it's fun
there's a lot of dates
there we go uh so you can try it for
free and if you like to buy it later
it's now for sale on sale as well fifty
percent off on both the microsoft store
and steam so
can pick it up as well opportunity um
i'm really looking forward to all of
those i'm curious though as i've been
walking around gamescom i've been seeing
loads of people repping age of empires
swag yes um is there anything that you
want to maybe showcase what's available
online or maybe for folks while they're
here well we have we have one more
announcement and then it's probably
going to be the least sexy thing that
we'll see in this boat broadcast
so we're gonna unbutton a bit and we're
gonna show oh yes we are going to be
celebrating uh 25 years of age of
empires
later this year so the 25th october yeah
it's been 25 years since the original
release 5 25. we're gonna be celebrating
with all the games in the franchise
everybody's invited and uh yeah it's
gonna be lovely it's gonna be an online
global event there will be more
announcements uh so i would say as as a
developer but also as a fan like you you
will not tune in you don't want to miss
it really and you've got your twitter
you're at age of empires to find out
more information websites
exactly uh just look age vampires on any
social media you'll be uh definitely
kept up to date amazing i'm also curious
um i shared a picture on my twitter last
night i mentioned i was at gamescom
there's some red bulls around are you up
to something with red bull at the moment
uh yes we are yes we are so uh red bull
uh wallolo
legacy is coming up it's uh it's a big
tournament uh where we're covering hvac
one two and four uh-huh uh and we also
will end of october that will culminate
in the large finals in a castle here in
germany that's
that's pretty cool i do have to ask
though are we playing the game or is it
just people going wall or law and seeing
who does it best we we are playing the
game but i definitely want that to be a
tiebreaker or something uh we need to
have it in there as well just add some
spice you know i i'd like to see that
i'd like to see that so yeah the best
players in the world all gathering
together in a german castle here playing
age of empires
for many it's childhood dream again it
sounds like
true honestly and i have got to ask the
shirt is it's catching the light so well
right now i do need my own version is
there a way for folks to get their hand
on that shirt yes this shirt is
available on the xbox gear shop as well
uh alongside a lot of other uh age
vampires t-shirts and merchandising so
yeah a lot to pick up there amazing i
know what i'm doing next right but it's
been phenomenal to have you here i've
loved talking to you and of course
everyone else who's tuned in today that
is the end of the show uh so for any
segments you might have missed from
today's live show or for those who just
want to relive today i know i certainly
do uh you can go back and watch the full
show on twitch or youtube and keep the
conversation going using the hashtag
xboxgamescom on social but that is it
for me this is the end of our epic
livestream here from the xbox booth at
gamescom this has been so much fun but
maxine graham let's close this out
[Applause]
all right everyone it has been such a
pleasure being back at gamescom with you
this year surrounded by these amazing
xbox fans and community and of course
you maxie too it is it is so now we're
going to be signing out from cologne
germany we'll see you next time bye
[Applause]
you